EVERYONE WELCOME TO THE SENATE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR
MEETING. WE ARE. START. M.
WE'RE GOING TO START OFF WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES AND IS THE NUMBER ONE
IS THE STATE WIDE CHEN C.
MANAGEMENT FUNCTIONS. SO WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE HAVE A
VOTE ON THE CALENDAR. ITEMS
NUMBER. ONE THREE. WELL WE HAVE
LET ME LET ME JUST TART OVER
ISSUES ONE THREE FIVE. NINE
HAVE A RECOMMEND APPROVED AS
BUDGETED SO I PREPARED
ENTERTAIN THAT MOTION. SOME OF.
MOTION IS MADE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CENTER CABALLERO BY THEIR
NIELSEN. SENATOR DRUG SO.
MOVING ON ISSUE NUMBER FOR THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO REJECT THE
BUT BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE IS A
PROMOTION TO THAT EFFECT. THERE
IS A MOTION THE REAL PLACE
CENTER CABALLERO HI THERE
NIELSEN. CENTER DRAWS SO. AND
THEN ISSUE NUMBER TWO AND
NUMBER THREE. I AM SORRY TO AND
NUMBER SIX. PROVE AS BUDGET.
SOME THERE IS A MOTION. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CENTER CABALLERO
I CENTER NIELSEN SENATOR SO.
VERY GOOD THAT CONCLUDES OUR
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR AND SO WE
HAVE SOME DISCUSSION ITEMS AND
WE'LL START OFF WITH TO DEPART
DEPART OF FISCAL. ISSUE NUMBER
TEN WHICH IS THE BEST A PROJECT
REPORT EIGHT UP UPDATE. THE
WELCOME THE WITNESSES TO COME
FOR FORWARD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS MERRIAM BARCELONA
ENGINE YOU KNOW AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FINANCIAL
INFORMATION SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIA. AND DID HAVE JUST
HAND AS I BELIEVE I'VE GIVEN TO
ALL OF YOU CAN ADVANCE. I CAN
GET INTO SOME. THANK YOU SO
DISCOUNT IS GOING TO START AT
THE TOP WITH THAT KIND OF WHERE
WE ARE TODAY I JUST GOT CAN BY
THE NUMBERS WE HAVE A HUNDRED
TO DEPART UTILIZING ASSIST. ALL
DEPARTMENTS UTILIZE IT FOR PART
IN BUDGETING I HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO OF THOSE DEPARTMENTS USE IT
FOR THE ACCOUNTING SYSTEM
EIGHT. THE END. PLEASE
UTILIZING THE SYSTEM OF THAT
OKAY HAVE HUNDRED AND FIVE
DOLLARS A BUNCH EXPENDITURES
ARE COURTED AT THREE TO THE
FISCAL SYSTEM AND TRACKED IS
TWO TRILLION DOLLARS IN CASH
MANAGEMENT THAT HAPPENS IN THE
SYSTEM. TRAY THIS HUNDRED
TWENTY OVER TWENTY THOUSAND.
VENDORS ARE SOME BUSINESS WITH
THE STATE CALIFORNIA THROUGH
OUR CALLIE PROCURE UM SYSTEM.
WE HAD THAT IS FAR IS TO MEET
IN THE SYSTEM. A NINETY FOUR
PER OF AVAILABLE RATE OR BETTER
WE ARE IN THE TRANSIT
TRANSACTION SPEED IS COMPARABLE
BETTER. YOU ARE IT IN SOME
CASES THAN WAR SECTOR SYSTEMS
AND THE MOST RECENT ONE WE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO
ABOUT SPEED IN AND HOW THEY ARE
MANAGED. THEIR LARGE STATE WAS
WITH THAT. STEM WE ARE PRICE
LOOK. SIGN IN FOR ACCESS TO ALL
OF THE DIFFERENT SYSTEMS THAT
MAKE UP THE FISCAL SYSTEM SO
AGAIN YOU HAVE THAT ONE POINT
OF ENTRY YOUR BEHIND WITH ALL
OF THE SECURITY OF THE LEVELS
IN. PLACE AS YOU. ALL HE
RECEIVED AT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
TO FINALIZE THE SCO
FUNCTIONALITY WHICH INCLUDED
THE CASH MANAGEMENT FUNCTION AS
WELL AS THE BUILDING OF THE
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER TO
PRODUCE THE STATE WIDE CALF FOR
BY THE STATE COMPTROLLER. WE
HAVE DOLLARS AT LAST THE CITY
REQUEST WAS FIFTY EIGHT OVER
THREE YEARS. TO PROVIDE
CUSTOMERS SUPPORT AS WELL AS
ENHANCE AND FROM- TO DEVELOP
ENHANCED TOOLS TO ASSIST THE
DEPARTMENTS THOSE TOOLS ARE LIE
AS WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
RIPPING OUT OUR BE I'VE BY
MICROSOFT. WHICH AGAIN IS BEING
ADDED RIGHT NOW WILL BE OUT ALL
OF THE DEPARTMENTS. AS OF APRIL
FIRST EIGHT AND WE'VE ALSO DONE
AND IT'S BEEN WE'VE MOVED A
SIGNIFICANT OUR ENVIRONMENT UP
TO THEM. WEB SERVICES AS WELL
AS YOU KNOW LOOKING AT OTHER
CLOUD I'M SERVICES THREE ASHER.
IN ALL OF IT AND STE IN HAPPENS
ME IT'S TIME TO SIT. AND THAT
WE HAVE THAT RIGHT NUMBER OF
ENVIRONMENTS WHAT WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT ENVIRONMENTS BUT THE
DEPARTMENTS TO COME IN AND TO
DO THEIR TESTING. I WE'RE
SEEING- FOR OVER A YEAR. THOSE
STAFF IN THE CON RESOURCES WE
WERE ABLE TO PUT INTO THE
DEPARTMENTS ALONG WITH THE
TREMENDOUS EFFORT OF OUR FOR
PARTNER COLLECTIVELY. THE 20%
PROVE MEANT I'M YEAR OVER YEAR
IN BE INDICATE. OF HOW THE
DEPART DOING. I AM INCREDIBLY
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY TO
INFORM YOU THAT WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF CLOSING OUT THE
MAJORITY THE PROP. IN FRONT OF
YOU HAVE- THE LONG. TABLE THAT.
HAS ALL OF THE ACROSS THE TOP
OF IT ARE ALL THE REQUIREMENTS
WE HAVE IN THE- AB PROJECT
DOCUMENT AS THE FIST CAL
PROJECTS SUPPOSED TO DELIVER
AND THEN ALONG THE CALL. CATCH
JACK DOZEN STEP COURSE ARE
THOSE THINGS THAT ARE ON WITH
THE THAT WE WILL CONTINUE ON
NOW THAT WE ARE DEPARTMENT AT.
TWENTY SIXTEEN A CROP TOP OF
THOSE CLOTHES THE LAST ONE IS
THE T. OF AN ALLEY AND ALL OF
THE FUNCTION BE A C. L. WILL
PLEASE IN. JUNE JULY. IT ON
YOUR FORM AS WITH AN ASTERIX
THAT THAT HE'S- IS DELAYED AT
THIS POINT WE ARE. THE WE JUST
WERE THAT YOU ARE STEERING
COMMITTEE. WE THINK THAT IS
ANYWHERE BETWEEN A SIX MONTH IN
THE YEAR DELAY AT THIS POINT
BUT WE ARE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH WITH- BUT ALSO WE ARE
MOSTLY WORKING CD KEY I AM THE
L. LATEST ON. EVERY LEVEL RIGHT
AND HOW TO. SURE THAT PASSED
KEEP. FINISH LINE AND- THE LA I
CAN THAT THAT PIECE THAT. WE
ARE ALSO. AT AT THE FOR TURN IT
OVER TO MY PARTNERS WHO ARE
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE CLOTHES
FUNCTIONALITY FROM EACH OF
THEIR RESPECTIVE RESPONSIBILITY
AREA. I DID WANT TO MANY OF YOU
HAVE ASKED ABOUT THE DEFERRED
DEPARTMENT. WE HAVE NINE TO FOR
WELL YES WITH NINETY
DEPARTMENTS ONE. ONE YES WHY.
THEY WERE EIGHT OR DO GAP
ANALYSIS FOR SAY INDICATED WE
WERE GONNA AGAIN UTILIZE SOME
OF THE FILES WERE FROM A PROPER
LAST YEAR TO DO THIS. SO WE ARE
BATES WE GOT INTO THE REMAINING
DEPARTMENTS UNDERSTOOD THEIR
CURRENT TO. LEGACY SYSTEM THERE
CURRENTLY ARE P. SYSTEM THAT
THEY HAVE. I AM WHEN IT WITH
THE THEIR USEFUL LIFE WHAT ARE
THE FUNDS NOW HE SAID I HAVE
DON'T I NEED TO OUR FACES FOR.
OR AT ALL NOW. TELL YOU IS
HAPPENING NOW IN WE WILL BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE A SCHEDULE ONCE
THAT INITIAL ASSESSMENT WE
LEVEL SCHEDULE AS TO WHEN WE
THANK YOU TO THE DEPRIVE COMING
ON AND NO EFFORT. FROM AN
INITIAL NOW THIS. I WOULD NOW
IF IT'S PLEASES TO THE CHAIR
OKAY WITH IT WITH TERRA WOULD
LIKE TO BRING UP MY FOR
PARTNERS TO TALK THERE WAS.
CLOSE IT THAT WOULD. START WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES AFFECT OKAY YES.
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR SENATORS PLEASE ENTER
TERM GOALS NINE THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR NEW PATIENT
GENERAL SERVICE WITH ME TODAY'S
ANGELES SHALL DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE PROCUREMENT DIVISION.
RIGHTS REAL LIFE EXAMPLE OF HOW
FISCAL HAS IMPROVED STATE
OPERATIONS AND SPECIFICALLY
TRANSPARENCY. WILL GIVE
EXAMPLES FROM FOR AREA.
STATEWIDE PROCUREMENT STATEWIDE
SITE OUR OWN DEPARTMENTAL
OPERATIONS FINALLY REPORTING.
THANK MANY OF YOU WILL KNOW IS
THE STATE'S OPERATIONS ARM AND
PROVIDES A VARIETY OF SERVICES
DEPARTMENTS AND OVERSEE STATE
AGENCY OPERATIONS FOR MEN.
MANAGED STATE TO STATE.
PROCUREMENT SPECIFIC TRANSITION
THIS GAL HAS HELPED US GAIN
INSIGHT ON WHAT THE STATE IS
BUYING FROM WHO AND FOR WHAT
PRICE. IT'S CAL HAS CENTER
ISN'T STANDARDIZED DETAIL
PROCUREMENT THAT. WE'RE NOT
USING TO MAKE BETTER DECISIONS
BUT WE'RE ALSO SHARING WITH THE
PUBLIC NOW. THROUGH SCOUT WE
NOW HAVE A SINGLE THAT ALLOWS.
I AM ACCURATE PORTING EACH DOOR
PART AND- TOTAL. REAL TIME DATA
HAS REDUCE BURDENSOME REPORT
IT'S FOR A DEPARTMENTS AS ALSO
ALLOWING TGS MORE STRATEGIC AND
WHERE WE FOCUS OUR RESOURCES
THE WHITE CONTRACTING EXPERTS.
MAKING IT A PUBLIC IS AN OP OR
SMALL BUSINESSES TABLE. IS TO
SEE YOU NEED EXISTS TO DO
BUSINESS WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE PUBLIC. ALL
BUSINESS AND DISABLE THAT
ENTERPRISE SPENDING DASHBOARD
USING THE PROCUREMENT DATA FROM
THE SYSTEM TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS SUCH AS DOES THE
STATE BY ITSELF. WHAT
DEPARTMENTS I BY MY GOOD AND
SERVICES. HOW FREQUENTLY. ONLY
ONE MY- I'M ABLE TO TRACKS
SPENDING WITH BUSINESSES IN
STABLE VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES IN REAL TIME. WHAT
PART IN SUBMITTED PAPER BASED
ANNUAL REPORTS. FROM IS OFTEN
DO NOT KNOW THEIR OWN SPF. THEN
UNTIL THE END OF THE YEAR. THEY
HAVE THEIR OWN HOME THE TRY WAS.
FROM OVERSIGHT FISCALES HELP
TGS STANDARDIZED PROCUREMENT
PRACTICES ACROSS ALL
DEPARTMENTS. THIS GETS BACK TO
PURCHASE FOR A MOMENT IT WAS
REAL DID THREE PERMANENT
INVOICE IN THE EVENING AND ALL
THE WAY TO PAINT. THIS PROP
FREQUENTLY IS WRECKED. CORRECT
PERFORMANCE SCALE ARE USING THE
SYSTEM'S CAPABILITIES GREATLY
REDUCING THE NEED TO MAKE
COPIES OF PERFILES. THE SAME
GOES FOR OUR FLEET MANAGEMENT
THE AUTOMATED STEPS WE BUILT
FISCAL ASSETS PURPOSE PROPERLY
INDISPOSED. IT'S GOT WE HAVE
IMPROVED VISIBILITY AND
TRACKING OF ASSETS TRANSFERRED
BETWEEN AGE IS PRIOR TO HIS
SCALP TRACK THE TRANSFERS WAS
CONDUCTED THROUGH A MANUAL LOOK
UP PROCESS OF AGENCIES PAPER
BASED FOR ITS- THE DEPARTMENT
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT THE GSS
DURING THEM. WHICH WHEN WE DO.
TRANSFER PROCESS INCLUDING
ACCESS TO DETAILED INVOICES AT
THE LINE ITEM LEVEL. AS A
DEPARTMENT YOU SCALE TGS IS NOW
USING THE WEALTH OF DATA WITHIN
THE SYSTEM TO BETTER PERFORMER
OWN ACTIONS. LAST YEAR WE
LAUNCHED AN INTER BUDGET TO
BULLS DASHBOARD THAT IS REAL
TIMES. A DETAILED. STATE STAFF
USING A COMMONLY AVAILABLE
BUSINESS INTELLIGENCE TOOL
BUILT THE DASHBOARD UPDATES
WEEKLY WITH FINANCIAL
TRANSACTION DETAILS FROM THE
SYSTEM. INTERNALLY WITH
DASHBOARD ACCEPT EVERY TGS
EMPLOYEE. THE DASHBOARD IS
ALLOWING A PROGRAM STAFF TO
MAKE INFORMED SPENDING
DECISIONS MORE QUICKLY OF
RACIAL NEEDS WE HAVE UP UNDER
DEVELOPMENT AND WORKING. THIS
SURE THE BULLS ACROSS THE STATE.
IN CLOSING REMARKS TODAY GIVE
YOU A BIG PICTURE SENSE OF
POWER DEPARTMENTS IN THE STATE
CAN AND ARE USING TO GO THROUGH
MY PROCESSES IN SHORT IT OVER
SO. PROVIDE LEAN DATA. I
CONFORM TO SET. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT I NEED TO COME UP.
ONE MORNING MAN CHAIR AND
SENATORS RICHARD GO HAND
APARTMENT FINANCE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING WHILE MOST ENGINEER IT.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION
ON THE FIRST THEY JUST WANTED
MAKE A FEW NOTES THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE RESPECT ALSO CONTEXT
FOR. THE CITY. THE DATE FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE OF OUR CORE
RESPONSE OF IS DEVELOPING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE ULTIMATELY THAT
PROCESS WHICH WE'RE GOING
THROUGH TODAY IT WAS AN AN
INACTIVE BUDGET. LEE SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN. JULY THIRTY OF EVERY
YOU ALL WELL KNOW. FOR THE LAST
FOUR FISCAL YEARS WE'RE TO SAY
THE BUT THE ENACTED BUDGET
PRESENTED TO THE TO THE TO PASS
A PART SAME. THAT WE BUILD THE
GOVERNOR. THAT WHICH IS. IN
CHANGE FROM FROM DECADES OF
THIS ORDER YOU BUDGETS WHEN YOU
WOULD LOOK AT THE BUDGET REAL
TO THE GOVERNOR IT WAS IT WAS
VERY HIGH LEVEL SUMMARY DETAIL
AND- THE DRILL DOWN AND SEE YOU
KNOW WHAT FINAL ACTION ARE.
WITH THE ENACTED BUDGET WE
PRESENT THE SAME LEVEL OF
DETAIL THAT WE PRESENT THE
LEGISLATURE IN JANUARY PRESENT
THE LEGISLATURE'S FIND OPTIONS
I'M BY THE GOVERNOR THE PUBLIC
THAT SAME WITH THE- SO WE-
EXPENSES. BUT IT'S ALSO WORTH
NOTING THOSE BUDGETS WERE ALL
COMPLETELY. IS MISTER ENGINEER
NOTED WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TO OUR DEPARTMENT USING
THE SYSTEM EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
ACTIVE USERS. TWO TRILLION
DOLLARS AS MANAGEMENT MOVEMENT
WE TRACK OVER THREE HUNDRED AND
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
BUDGETARY EXPENDITURES SO. WE
HAVE HAD SOME CHALLENGES WE HAD
SOME DIFFICULTY ON SOME OF OUR-
MONTH AND YEAR AND CLOSE ISSUES
WHICH- OUR COLLEAGUES WILL TALK
ABOUT AS WELL- WITH THE
LEGISLATURE OF WITH. WE WE'RE
RESOURCES THAT WE RECEIVED IN
LAST BUDGET AS WE SPEAK AND
THEY ARE PROVING BENEFICIAL AND
SO WE THANK LEGISLATURE FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
COULD ANSWER TO ME. THANK YOU
VERY. UNDER RIVERA WITH THE
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE. I'M
ASSUMING YOU'RE ALL GONNA STAY
SO THAT WE CAN ASK QUESTIONS WE
NEED. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
SENATORS. MY NAME IS ANDREA
VERA ON THE STEERING COMMITTEE
MEMBER AS WELL- AS IS DEBT
DIRECTOR IN THE CENTRALIZED
TRADE. IS MANAGEMENT AND FOR
THE STATE CHARGES OUT. AS THE
STATE'S BANKER THE TREASURE
OVERSEES ALL BANKING ASPECTS OF
THE CENTRALIZED FRAZIER SYSTEM.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN OUR
OFFICE WITH LIVE IN FISCALE
ACCOUNTING AND PURCHASING
FUNCTION. AND IN OCTOBER TWO
OCTOBER TWO THAT BEING WE
SUCCESSFULLY INCORPORATED OUR
CONTROL EXTERNALITY BY
IMPLEMENTING THE TREASURES CASH
MANAGEMENT PROCESSES INTO
FISTS. AND OTHERS HAVE
MENTIONED OVER TWO TRILLION
DOLLARS IN ACTION OKAY BORN
FISCAL. PARDON ME. ALL STATE
REVENUES AND PAYMENTS MADE ARE
NOW RECORDED DISCO. STATE
DEPARTMENT TELL BILLY TO LOG
INTO FISCALE ELECTRONICALLY AND
SUBMIT THEIR DEPOSITS. OR A
DEPOSITORY BANKS CAN NOW SEND
IN THEIR DAILY FILES DIRECTLY
INTO FISCALE WHICH ARE
AUTOMATICALLY LOADED INTO
SYSTEM WITHOUT INTERVENTION.
BANK RECONCILIATION THIS IS
THIS INFORMATION TO RECONCILE
AGENCY DEPOSITS AGAINST BANK
DEPOSIT TO ENSURE ACCURATE AND
THE REPORTING. ADDITIONALLY WE
COURT OUR ACCOUNTING ENTRIES IN
ADJUSTMENTS THROUGH FISCALE
ELIMINATING PAPER-
DOCUMENTATION. AND LASTLY
DEPARTMENTS CAN NOW REPORT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE BANK
ACCOUNTS WITH- IN OR OUT OF THE
STATE TREASURY- AND THIS WAS A
MANUAL AND TIME CONSUMING
PROCESS PART OF FISCAL. YOU FOR
YOU MY BE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU. PUBLISHED THANK YOU
VERY. AND FINALLY I'D LIKE TO
BRING MY PARTNER FROM A STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE DAVE OF
DOUBLE. GOOD MORNING NOW MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. OF MY NAME
IS ABLE TO A LOT PERCENT THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AS ONE OF
THE PARTNERS OF THE- PROJECT.
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE HAS. TO
PROJECT. SIR CAN HIM COMMITTEE
MEMBER SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE
AND HAS BEEN AN ACTIVE. IN AND
DEVELOPING OF THE SKULL SYSTEM.
US I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY DESCRIBE
A FEW FISCAL SYSTEMS SAID IN
FUNCTIONS AT- ALL THE WORK TO
WHICH- OF UNDER DID MANAGE
FILE. OUT OF HIS COMA I WITH
THE CENTRAL VENDOR MANAGEMENT
FILE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. THE
AMOUNT IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
INTEGRITY COUNTY TRANSPARENCY
FOR STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
RELATED. OFFICE THE PART TO USE
A CENTRAL. WHICH IS MAINTAINED
BY THE CONTROL OFFICE OF THE
VET VMF APPROVES FISCAL
CONTROLS AND DECISION MAKING BY
STATE MANAGED AND LET HER IN
ORDER TO ENHANCE THE QUALITY
TIMELINESS DISTANCE SEE. AN
IMPOSSIBLE UNDER. THE TOUGHEST.
AN ACTOR REPORT. REST IN NINETY
NINE FORTY WITH IT WITHIN OUR
AUDITS THE STATE CONTROLLER'S
AUDITS DIVISION ANSWERS FOR
AUDITING ALL FUNDS DISPERSED BY
THIS. ALL CLAIMS PRESENTED FOR
PAYMENT TO THE CAN STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE THE AUDITS
DIVISIONS UTILIZE THE AUDITING
FUNCTIONS IN FISCAL TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. AND FOR
THOSE DEPARTMENTS FOR LEASING
FIST. AND OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS WE HAVE BEEN WORKING TO
INTEGRATE THE STATE COMPTROLLER
IN THE TRASH OFFICE FUNCTIONS
INTO THE FISCAL SYSTEM-
DEPLOYMENT OF THE DEPLOYMENT OF
THE INTEGRATED SOLUTION. UNTIL
THE EIGHTEEN. NEW FICTION HELPS
OF CONTENTS CONTINUE. WE LAST
EMPLOYED. MAIN COUNTRIES AND
NINE. AND FINALLY THE
CONTROLLERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO A THE COMMITTEE
ABOUT. I THINK VERY MUCH. WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE SYSTEM IS-
WHILE IT IS FUNCTIONAL AND IT
IS OUT THE COMPARTMENTS ARE
UTILIZING IT WEARING PROUD OF
IT- THE DEPARTMENT. IS KEEPING
YOU TO COME UP AND GET THE
HABIT AND IF IT OUT. EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN CANCER IS
TO THE SYSTEM AT THE REQUEST OF.
PARTNER OR THE MEANS. AND WE
HAVE ANOTHER SIXTY IN IN THE
PROCESS PLAY- ENHANCEMENTS ON A
MONTHLY BASIS INTO THE SYSTEM
AND WE ARE COMMITTED. MAKING
SURE THAT. WE ARE PROVIDING THE-
FASTEST MOST SECURE SYSTEM WE
CAN'T THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
MUCH APPRECIATE ALL THE TESTS
I'M HERE TODAY COMMENTS THE LA.
THAT'S GREAT LA JUST WANTED NOT
JUST THE- PROGRESS OF THE
REPORT OF THE PROJECT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ALREADY
MENTIONED IN THEIR TESTIMONY.
AND ALSO ONE APPRECIATE THE
SUMMARY OF OUR REPORT THAT WE
ISSUED IN JANUARY IN THE- WALL
HIGHLIGHTED OF. TWENTY TWENTY
ARMY REMOVED SOME ACTIVITIES
AND FUNCTIONS FROM THE PROJECT
SCOPE AS WELL AS INCREASE THE
TOTAL PROJECT COST BY A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY. DOLLARS THE MINT
WHICH- BRING COSTS FOR THE
PROJECT. I THE SECOND IS THAT
THE LATEST PROJECT PLAN
INTRODUCED A NEW DEFINITION OF
BUDGET COMPLEXION THAT WOULD
NOT IMPLEMENT ALL OF THE PLAN
FUNCTIONS OF THE CAL SYSTEM.
FOUND IN OUR ASSIST. PHOENICIAN
WAS INCONSISTENT WITH. ALUMINUM
TATIAN AND STATE IT POLICY THE
THIRD WAS THAT THE LATEST
PROJECT PLAN DID NOT ACCOUNT
FOR ALL OF THE COSTS THAT ARE
SO IT'D WITH DISCOUNTS. IN THE
COST STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
TO AND HAVE A GREAT. THE CARD
IS FOR DEPARTMENT USE THE
FISCAL SYSTEM. IN THE ANTI
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR EXAMPLE
DEPARTMENT USING THE FISCAL
SOME ARE REQUESTING A TOTAL OF
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS A
HUNDRED AND TWO POINT SINCE.
FOR EXAMPLE THE ADDITIONAL.
THIS REPORT TO SYSTEM. THE MOST
RECENT. REPORT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY RATES
THE PROJECT AS RED WHICH MEANS
IT IS ESCALATE IT FOR IMMEDIATE
IMMEDIATE CORRECTIVE ACTION AND
THAT THERE IS THIS A RISK TO
THE PROJECT THE PROJECT- OF THE
STRESS AND IT LIKELY NEED TO
PROVIDE PROJECT. THIS IS THE
THING THAT IS FOR THE PROJECT
WITH THE- WITH T. IN TIME WE
CONTINUE TO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTS STATUTORY
LANGUAGE THAT THE FILE IN
SURPRISE WE XIN AND THAT'S FOR
THE FOR. WHILE IT WAS BRIEFLY
MENTIONED HERE WE WOULD ALSO
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE ASKED
THE ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE
AN UPDATE STATUS OF EIGHT
NINETEEN CONCRETE IN PARTICULAR
THE ABILITY OF SEVERAL LARGE
DEPARTMENTS TO CLOSE THEIR YEAR
END FINANCIAL STATEMENTS IN THE
FISCAL SYSTEM. AS CALIFORNIA
NOTED ONE OF HER RECENTLY.
THERE ARE RISKS TO THE STATE
FROM. OVER YOU SAID AT THE TEN.
CHEN AND SOME HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ONE TO GIVE YOU
AN OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND TO
THOSE. BEFORE WE GET TO A
QUESTIONS IF THAT'S OKAY SO
WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU I MISSED MASSACRE AT
THE REMOVAL OF SOME OF THE KEY
FUNCTIONALITY AGAIN THE STATE
COMMITTEE. AT THE ENTITY MY FOR
PARTNERS DETERMINE WHAT ARE
THOSE KEY FUNCTIONALITIES MAKE
A SYSTEM THE SYSTEM WORKED
PROPERLY AND AGAIN IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN ONE PART IN IT IT
ENABLED US FOR THAT LONG TERM
HOW DO WE DO SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE WOULD TO HAVE. THAT ARE
NOT NECESSARY TO HAVE. WE ARE
WERE. THE STAFF. I AM. TO FIND
WHAT WHAT IS LEFT OUT OF YES
THE FUNCTION SO THAT WE CAN
APPROPRIATELY DEVELOP THE
SCHEDULE AND WE- USE WHATEVER
PROJECT AB PLAN IS ULTIMATELY
DECIDED UPON BY CD THE ALLY
WHEN I. GO WE WILL CAN TO
DEPLOY THE PUNCH ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE CONTRACT WILL
BE DEPLOYED. USUALLY HAVE IS MY
IS MY WHAT NOW WHAT WAS THE
PROJECT SET OUT TO YOU
CONTRACTUALLY WELL MY MANDATE
IS MUCH LARGER THAN THAT AND
STATUTES AND WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT- IT ME INTEREST
RIGHT THERE JUST MADE ME. THE
THIS. BECOMES A IMPORTANT. AS
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT THE
STATE IS TIED WITH I KEEP
PROJECTS AND- AND WITH THE FACT
THAT- THIS PARTICULAR VENDOR
HAS ISSUES WITH THE STATE IN
THE PAST SO I WANT TO MAKE AT
THAT UP AND HAVE A- IDEA OF
WHAT IS SIX WHAT IS AND YOUR-
GONNA GO THE- WE- SOME POINT
YOU HAVE TO SEE THEM COMING
DOWN THE PIKE IN AND NO THIS IS
COSTA FOR AN- THAT. THERE'S A-
NOW THIS IS THAT SAYS WITH THE
LANGUAGE YOUR TECH CLAIM IS AND
THE CONTRACT IS ENDED- AND THAT
IT. IS THAT DEPARTMENTS THAT
MOST SHOULD BENEFIT FROM THE IF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
PROGRAM AND AFTER THAT'S THE
QUESTIONS I HAD. THANK YOU FOR
TWENTY MILLION DOT. THIRTY TWO
CAN SPEAK. BECAUSE I'VE MY
QUESTION WAS GOING TO BE. MOM
ASSUMING THAT DEFICIENCIES THAT
HAVE BEEN CREATED THAT WE
SHOULD BE SAVING MONEY AND- IT
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE WE'RE NOT
SAVING MONEY IT'S OUR WORK INTO
M. WHEN ONE OF THEM ONE IS.
DONE AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
WE HAVE A LOT MORE WORK THAT
NEEDS DONE AND WE COME BACK AND
I'M BECAUSE NEED SPEND MORE
MONEY TO BUILD MORE
FUNCTIONALITY THE END THAT WE I
MISSED IF WE DISCOVERED IN THIS.
GET ADDITION. REGIONAL CONTRACT
HOW IT SHOULD BE POSITIVE SO
THAT WE'RE ALL AWARE OF THE
FACT THAT WHAT WE ASK FOR WAS
DELIVERED- THEY'RE MORE THAT HE
WANTED TO GET AN WHERE WE KNOW
WE ARE RIGHT NOW SO. IT'S
THREE. THANK YOU MADAM TO COME
A FIVE RECORD PLEASE THESE ARE
MY IF I MISSED ANY OF YOUR BUT
WHAT WHAT RESPECT I THINK THERE
SORT KNOWS. BY SOME FOLKS WANT
THE PROJECT THE IS TRYING TO
GET OUT FROM UNDER OVERSIGHT
THIS PROJECT I JUST WANT TO
STATE ON THE RECORD THAT THAT
IS ABSOLUTELY THE CASE I THE
SEMESTER IS. THIS PROJECT
BRINGS ALLOW. THE STATE BUDGET
EXPENDITURES THAT WOULD NEVER
HAD BEFORE WE THINK THAT SERVES
THE PUBLIC INTEREST AND- WHAT
WE ARE INTERESTED IN I WAS
HAVING A CONVERSATION WITH
IDENTITY AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE OF COURSE ABOUT
WHAT'S THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL
FOR SITE AND WHAT SHOULD
OVERSIGHT ON HIS IS MISSING
GINNY DOES STATED IN OUR
TESTIMONY AS WITH. THE PRIOR
HERE. IN PRODUCTION. HE IS IT
FOR SOME IT A SIGNAL A CRITICAL
PORTION OF FUNCTIONAL BUT BUT
IN IN THE OVERALL CONTEXT IT'S
A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF REMAINING
FUNCTION IS LEFT TO DO AND WE
THINK THAT'S WHERE THE
OVERSIGHT SHOULD BE FOCUSED BUT
AGAIN WE ARE NOT LET UNLIMITED
PER SITE WE'RE NOT GONNA LOOK
FOR THE END TO GET AROUND FROM
OVER WE'RE HAPPY CAN DOES THIS
IN SO. WE CAN LANDED UP BECAUSE
OF. I SAID AT THE- PROJECT.
VENUS INTO THE TWENTY CENTURY I
DON'T RECALL EARLY I IF WE MAKE
AN EFFORT AND SECURE CALL
SAVINGS IT WAS MORE REPLACE
HUNDREDS A LEGACY SYSTEMS A TO
BECOME CREATE COMP BECAUSE OR
MAINTAIN. THOSE TECHNO THAT
THIS SETS ARE NOT OF IN THE
MARKET PLACE AND ARE NOT BEING
TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS ANYMORE. I'M
AND SO WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE SORT
OF A WHOLE. SMALLER AND SMALLER
GROUP OF PEOPLE LOT OF MURPHY
RETIRED STATE EMPLOYEES AT THAT
THOSE SKILL SETS THEY RETIRED
AND THEN THEY COME BACK TO WORK
OR TO SCHOOL. SOME OF THERE'S A
LOT OF. THE MOVE SHUT DOWN
HUNDREDS OF LEGACY SYSTEMS AND
MORE ARE BEING SHUT DOWN AS WE
SPEAK COULDN'T CAL STARS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M AND
IN FIVE WITH THIS LAST THE-
PLUS IT. THEY OP I THINK IT'S
LUMPED IN THE CON OF FISCAL
BILL. CAL DID. MRS LEE WAS
CHANGE THE WAY THE STATE DOES
ACCOUNTING AND MISS THE STATE
HAD DONE A CAPPING AWAIT THE
WAS VERY DIFFERENT FROM THE
REST OF THE WORLD. I'M NOT A
COUNTY- BUT WE HAVE THOSE
PEOPLE ARE. THEY CAN. YOU THE-
GRANULAR LEVEL OF DETAIL THAT
YOU MAY WISH TO UNDERSTAND BUT
IT IT FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
WAY ARE COUNTING WORKFORCE
WORKED AND WAS ABLE TO TALK TO
THEM SOMETHING UP BEFORE THAT
IN HINDSIGHT WITH THE BENEFIT
OF HINDSIGHT SHOULD HAVE DONE
MORE AND CHANGE. FOR WE
RECOGNIZE. AND WE'RE STILL
TAKEN SOME FOR THAT BUT WITH
THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORT WE
WE'RE DEPLOYING. AS IN THOSE
RESOURCES THE VA'S. ARE AT THE
PART COUNTY SHOPS OR TO SOME
DEPARTMENT COUNTERTOPS SO IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT FISCAL WITH THIS
GIRL DOES A PROVIDES A LEVEL
TRANSPARENCY THE STATE'S NEVER
HAD BEFORE WHERE OKAY TO. IT'S
FUN TO GO TO THE PARK. MONEY
BROKEN OUT IN THE DEPARTMENT.
USE THAT MONEY AND ON THE TGS
INTO THE PRODUCT. OKAY NOW SEE
HOW THEY'RE SPENDING NOW IN
WHAT VENDORS AND WHEN WHAT
THEY'RE BUYING AND SO. WE THINK
ALL THAT IS A VITAL STATE.
TRANSPARENCY CREATED A WORK.
MEANS THAT THEY DIDN'T HAVE
BEFORE. AND THAT'S THE PIECE
WITH WE'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH
NOW. WE THINK WE'RE GETTING
AHEAD OF IT. US TO DO AND-
QUESTION I DID I DRESS ALTER
YOUR QUESTIONS MANAGER I
BELIEVE THAT AND I THE ISSUE OF
THE I MEAN I GUESS WHAT I HEAR
YOU SAYING IS THAT IS IT'S
CLEAR. THAT WHAT WE ASKED FOR
FROM THE PROJECT IS ALMOST
COMPLETE. AND THAT THERE ARE
FEW TASKS LEFT THAT WILL BE
DONE BY THE JUNE. THIRTY AT
TWENTY TWENTY DATE. F. BUT IT
BECAUSE BECAUSE WHAT I HEAR
WHEN I HEAR THE LA- SAYING IS
THAT IS. THIS MAY BE
PERSPECTIVE- MAYBE I SHOULD ASK
WHETHER THAT NEW IF THE NEW
THAT THE INTEREST IN HAVING
LATE. DEAFENED DEFINITION- OF
END OF PROJECT- WOULD BE
PERSPECTIVE. BRENT METZ CURLY
YES SO THE DEFINITION OF
PROJECT COMPLETION THAT WE ARE
RECOMMENDING WOULD TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT SOME OF THE SCOPE THAT
WAS REMOVED WITH S. P. R.
EIGHT- EIGHT AND WOULD LOOK AT.
ALL THE WHAT WE FIND WITH IT
EIGHT AS KIND OF PROJECT
COMPLETION IT WAS A THERE WAS A
TO USE THAN AMONG. BACK IN ALL
JUST THAT WE- LEGISLATIVE. THE
ALTERNATE WE DO AND A BENCH BY
THE TO THERE ISN'T IT DELAY IN
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
ANTICIPATED TO BE DONE BY JUNE
THIRTIETH BUT WE ALSO SEE YOU
THERE SOME IN EXAMPLE.
INITIALLY DEFINED TEN TO
INCLUDE AN OF A- YOU. FINANCE
THE FISCAL. BECAUSE THEN THAT
WOULD AT LEAST GIVE US SOME
CONFIDENCE THAT FOR EXAMPLE THE
DATA IS BEING SHARED BETWEEN
THE FISCAL STIMULUS SYSTEM AND
WOULD GIVE US MORE CONFIDENCE
THAT WE CAN PRODUCE ACT SHOULD
ACCURATE FIND TO REPORTS STAT
GREAT SOLUTION IS DEPLOYED I'M
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS THAT
COULD BE DETERRED SUCH AS THE-
OF THE FUR DEPARTMENTS THAT'S
ALREADY. BACK ON HOW MANY HAVE
BEEN DE COMMISSIONED WHAT THE
SAVINGS WERE THEIR NUMBER WAYS
THAT THIS COULD BE DONE BUT FOR
US- RECOMMENDATION WAS TO FOCUS.
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE INTO WHEN
IT LOOKED AT THIS PROJECT
INITIALLY AND WHERE WE ARE NOW
AND I THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
DISCREPANCIES THERE BETWEEN THE
TWO. OKAY WE ARE WE ARE ARE
WORKING WITH WITH YOUR STAFF
AND AS WELL AS- CDT AND THE L.
L. TO COME TO A DEFINITION OF
WHAT BUT AS WE WERE WITH JUST A
POINT OF CLARIFICATION ON
SOMETHING THAT YOU STEP USE
YOU'D STATE. I JULY. TWENTY ALL
OF THE REQUIREMENTS NECESSARY
AND- FOR THE CONSOLIDATED CASH
RECORD COMING OVER AND INTO THE
INTO THE FISCAL SYSTEM FROM THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WHAT WILL
BE LEFT IN THE P. SAID IT'S
BEING DELAYED FURTHER IT IS THE
KEY. THE EXTENSION THAT THE TO
BE DEVELOPED IN ORDER TO
PRODUCE THE KAFFIR BY THAT THE
STATE COMPTROLLER WE'RE LOOKING
AT ABOUT SIX MONTHS RIGHT NOW
AS FAR AS BLAISE BUT I'VE ASKED
MY FROM WERE PRIMED AND NOT AND
WE'RE STILL BUILDING THE
SCHEDULE SO I DON'T HAVE A
MINIMIZED WE WANT TO CONSIDER A-
AS WE HAVE. A WE- FOR THIS I'M
AS- CAPRON OF THEIR SISTER SO
BEING ABLE TO DO BOTH AT THE
SAME TIME IF WHAT I'M HEARING
FROM THE L. L. IS THAT YOU WANT
TO. CAL TO BE. SERVICE THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT. TO GET THROUGH
BUT THE ACTUAL BUILDING- I'VE
THE- THE SYSTEM ITSELF. WE WILL
BE IN TESTING- IN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS ON AND GO. WE ARE NOT.
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE BEING VERY
CAUTIOUS IN MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE TESTING AND LOADING THE
CORRECT DATA INTOTHE SYSTEM.
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE BOTH THE
LEGACY SYSTEMS DATA AND OUR
SYSTEM FOR THE- AT. THE STATE
COMPTROLLER SORRY. TO BE ABLE
TO IT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE.
ARE MATERIALLY CENTERED SEC
RIGHT I'LL AND THAT IS AFTER
THAT WE WERE TAKING VERY
SERIOUSLY. I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE. WE ARE CONTINUE TO DO
A PANTS MISSILES I WAS TUNING.
SO ACT BOARDING DEFERRED TO
PART IT'S- WE EXPECT THAT EACH
ONE OF THOSE WILL GET I EXPECT
A CATHOLIC BUT- MY AND I
ANTICIPATE THAT YOU TO THOSE
DEPART WILL AT LEAST A TWO YEAR
ON BOARDING. WHAT SYSTEMS NEED
TO BE EITHER INTEGRATED I'M AND
HOW MUCH WORK WILL BE INVOLVED
IN THAT WE WILL BE COMING BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE. BOTH IN A
LEVELS WITHIN. IF WE SPECIFIC
ASKS I'M YOU KNOW. EITHER OUR
OUR VERY DEPART NEEDED
RESOURCES WE WOULD GO THROUGH
THE BUDGETING PROCESS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ULTIMATELY THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE. SO WHO WE WANT TO
BE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
FINISH THE EXISTING FISCAL
PROJECT WITH THE SCOPE- THERE
IS THERE IS A GREAT UPON WHEN
WE DO WITH THE AYE ALLEN JUST
LIKE HER WITH TO THE
DEPARTMENTS. WE'LL BRING TO
PLEDGES. ADD ON TO THAT MADAM
CHAIR I JUST JUST TO CLARIFY-
THIS DISCUSSION OF DEFERRED
DEPARTMENTS I THINK SOMETIMES
GETS. BASE A LITTLE BIT NOW AND
THAT THESE THE FOR DEPARTMENTS
WERE INTENDED TO BE DEFERRED
ALL ALONG THE DATA SAID MAY.
TEN TWELVE YEARS AGO THE ONSET
OF THIS PROJECT I AND THE
REASON I WAS AND. NO GOOD DEED
GOES UNPUNISHED- THAT THE THAT
DECISION WAS BECAUSE IT WAS IT
WAS TWO FOLD ONE WHEN WE ARE
YOU HELP PART OF THE TIME ARE
YOU SURPRISED SOURCE TO WITH
BUDGET IS A LARGE ENTERPRISE
RESOURCE I'M AND HAVE A COUPLE
THE WORD IN THE PLAN. THOSE I.
ENDS IN CRASH. AND DECIDED THAT
THOSE ENTITIES OF SCARED WHEN
ANOTHER ENOUGH IN IN A SCI THAT
IT WAS IN A BEST INTEREST AGO
PROCEED BECAUSE IT THEY
COULDN'T WAIT OR TEN FOR ALL
THE ONLINE AND SO IN THAT THIS
IS AT THAT TIME WAS ONCE WE GET
OF CAL. THEIR DATA IS IN FISCAL
IT'S IN THE NUMBERS YOU SEE
IT'S IN THE BUDGET NUMBERS
THERE'S NO MISSING PIECES THEIR
ATTENDANCE IS WENT WHEN DOES MY
BUSINESS THE CONVERT ON OVER
MEN AND SO THE THIS ONE I AM
IN. ONE AND TWO IT'S THE
DEPARTMENTS DID THAT UP TO
REFRESH THEIR EXIST SYSTEM THAN
PUT MONEY IN. MY TIME TO CUT
OVER BURKE. TOLD IN FISCAL AND
STUFF I JUST WANT THE DOT WAS
THE PLAN ALL AND THAT PART IS
NOT A- IS NOT A EIGHT. IN THEY
WERE WE'RE NOW IT POINT WE WERE
STARTING TO INVESTIGATE. WHEN
DO YOU KEEP THAT UP AND WE WILL
THE GLIDE PATH BRING YOU TO
THOSE. GOOD I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT HE- BECAUSE I. BECAUSE I
WAS PART OF THIS HEARING. BUT
THAT THE IT THE THEY WERE ROOM.
IN THE A P. R. A. AND SO IT.
NOT PART OF THAT SO I. THINK
YOU FOR THAT HIS. LESSON IN.
YOU HAVE. RIGHT NO HE- GOOD
DEED GOES UNPUNISHED I. JUST
HAVE. MORE QUESTIONS THEN ALL
OF I'LL- MOVE ON TO. THE WITH
THE WITH THE- SPEED OF THE
INFORMATION THAT COMES OUT OR-
ANY NEW NEEDS THAT THEY MAY
HAVE GIVEN THAT PROJECT HAS NOW
PRODUCED A WHOLE LOT OF
INFORMATION AND THEY ACTUALLY
WANT MORE INFORMATION SO ONE
WOULD BE AN ANTICIPATED RIGHT
MANAGEMENT IS WHEN THINGS. THAT
WE DON'T DO VERY WELL- IT IF
YOU IF YOU USE A LEAN SIX
PROCESS YOU CAN REALLY FIGURE
OUT WHERE YOU HAVE ALL THESE.
ENERGY CENTER SPENT THAT IT GO
TO WASTE THAT CREATE A LOT OF
BUREAUCRACY SO I APPRECIATE
THAT THAT COMMENT BUT- IT BACK
AT DEPARTMENT ISSUES. SO SOME
OF THE KEY ISSUES THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON LOOKING FOR
SOLUTIONS FOR- WERE A LOT OF A
WE GET THE BULK OF THE KIDS
COMING INTO MY SERVICE CENTER
FROM OUR- ARE. TO HOW DO I DO
SO VERSUS. IN DON'T HAVE. WE
HAVE WE'RE ALMOST AT ZERO
TICKETS THAT ARE ON SYSTEMS
IT'S VERY LOW NUMBERS BUT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE HOW TO
QUESTIONS WHAT WE HAVE DONE TO
HELP THOSE TO COMMENCE IS.
REDUCED A CHAP BRINGING WITH IT
SOME ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
AND WE TAUGHT AT FIRST AB THE
PROCUREMENT WORLD BECAUSE OUR
HIGHEST VOLUME OF TICKETS AND
HIGHEST VOLUME OF TRANSACTIONS
ON THIS. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
GETTING IS. OUT ABLE TO ANSWER
AND HAS ELIMINATED AND NOT THE
MAJORITY AGAIN OF THE QUESTION
THAT WE HAD BEEN SEEN ON A
ROUTINE BASIS BUT WE ALL
THOUGHT THE ROW COUNT RECEIVER
PEBBLE AND SO NOW WE WILL BE
DOING AS FAR AS THE YOU'RE IN A-
NOW. AND QUESTION ONE OF IT
TAKES. BACKERS AN EMAIL WHEN
IT'S HOW TO CA. WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING TO PUT ON SCREEN. ON IT.
ON TWO DIFFERENT SO YOU ARE SO
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LEAVE THE
PAGE YOU DON'T READ ANOTHER
SCREEN TO IT WOULD IT IT TO
REACH OUT TO US SO WE ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF THOSE OP ABOUT.
HAVE DONE IN THIS THIS REGARD.
WELL IT. PRIVATE SECTOR YOU
SOME SYSTEMS SOME OF THE OTHER
AREAS IN WHICH THE DEPARTMENT'S
STRUGGLE IS WE DO REQUIRE A
EVERY DETAIL AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION. AND THAT IS IN
ORDER FOR US ON THE FLIP SIDE
TO PROVIDE A LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO PROVIDE. DOING TO LOOK TO
HELP ADDRESS THAT IN IS IN OUR
OUR PIPELINE NOW IS SOME
ROBOTIC PROCESS AUTOMATION. SO
THAT VERY CERTAIN THINGS AND
I'LL I'LL USE A PO EXAMPLE
WHERE YOU ENTER. YOUR AND- MR
STORM HOUSES MENTIONED THAT HE-
STATION ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
THE PAYMENT TO THE THAT THE
THAT CHECK CORRECT TO CHECK.
ALONG THE WAY THERE ARE MANY
SCREEN WHICH ARE ENTERING SO
THE SAME INFORMATION YOU NEED
THAT PO NUMBER YOU NEED THE
ORDER NUMBER NEEDS TO BE
CROSSED SO WE'RE LOOKING AT.
ABOUT A- INTO TO PULL THAT WE
HAVE A- GROUP THAT YOU HAVE TO
MANUALLY. WHEN I WOULD IS THE
SAME THAT WAS HERE. THE WHERE
WITH A CUSTOMER. BASE OF FIFTY
TWO PARTS PARTICIPATING OF.
DEBT SEA SENATORS. IS TO THE
WERE CAST RIGHT NOW WE HAVE.
SUB WORKING GROUP. CHAIRED BY
DIFFERENT. AGENCIES REALLY- ONE
IS ON THE CONFIDENTIAL PH I.
INFORMATION. ON WHICH WE DO NOT
HAVE IN THE SYSTEM BUT HOW THEY
IN TURN INFORMATION THIS WORK
BY THE CONTROLLER. IT SAFE
MANNER WITHOUT PUT IT INTO A
FINANCIAL SYSTEM I THEN WE ALSO
HAVE. ON ROBOTICS OF SADDAM XIN
WITH BEING WANTED BY. AT IT WAS.
WITH HEALTH CARE AND THEN THE
THIRD ONE IS ARTIFICIAL AND-
ALLEGIANCE AND THEN GOING IN
THERE IS ALSO THE REPORTING.
CAPABILITIES FLYING SO WE ARE
TRYING TO PROVIDE MORE VENUES
FOR THE DEPARTMENTS TO COME IN
AND- AND THEN WE GO THROUGH A
PRIORITY SHOULD PROCESS IN
WHICH THE DEPARTMENTS HELP.
PRIORITIZE THROUGH THE CIC WHAT.
HAVE TO BE TO PLAY FIRST SECOND
THIRD WHAT ARE THOSE YOU KNOW
PEOPLE POINTS THAT RIGHT NOW IT
IS. I EIGHT ENTRY THEY WERE
GONNA STREAMLINE BUT THEN ON
THE OTHER SIDE IS THE
RECONCILIATION BETWEEN THE
FISCAL SYSTEM AND WHAT IS
CURRENTLY IN THE LEGACY I'M
SYSTEM TECH ROLLERS OFFICE CASH
BOOK OF RECORD WHERE MY RULE
AND SO WE IN THIS ABSTRACT THE
DISTANCE ALL SHE JULY THAT. I
DID YOU WELL FOR INSTITUTE
RECONCILIATION SELL WITH I
THINK THAT'S WHAT I'VE HEARD SO
WITH THAT CAN CAN YES OKAY THAT
COMING ON I'M YOU MEAN JUST IN
THIS FISCAL YEAR WE'RE HOPING
TO SEE SOME IMPROVEMENTS WILL
SUPPORT IT TOMATO
RECONCILIATION. ARE THOSE THE
AGAIN WILL ASSIST AND- THE
REMAINING FUNCTIONALITY IS A TO
POINT. VERY GOOD THANK YOU AND
ONE LAST QUESTION BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN HEARING FROM- SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT DO. WORK FOR
THIS. HAVE CONTRACTS. THAT THE-
DISPERSAL OR THAT THE CHECKS IN
THE MAIL- ARE VERY DELAYED AND-
AND I AND I JUST WONDER IF THAT
AB RESULT OF HAVING MOVED TO
THE SYSTEM OR WHETHER IT- IT'S
OLD INFORMATION I DID A FULL OF
TOURS THE- IT SAYS. AND ISSUE
IS THAT THEY THEY EXPECT A LOT
OF RESOURCES UP FRONT IN ORDER
TO. UNDER THE CONTRACT AND THEN
THEY THEY HAVE TO PAY FOR THAT
THAT MATERIALS THAT THEY USE
AND THEN THEIR THEIR CHECKS ARE
ARE SIGNIFICANT DELAY AND OF MY
AND THAT IT USED TO BE VERY
CLOSE. BEFORE BUT NOW IT KING A
LOT. I WONDER IF YOU IF YOU'VE
GOT SOME INSIGHT WE SHOULD JUST
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT. IT'S
THREE D. YES. I DON'T KNOW IF
AND KATHY WANTS TO COME UP AND
HELP ME WITH THIS FROM THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE I
KNOW THAT WE WERE HAVING
ISSUES- OR KLAY WITH WITH JUST.
THINGS LIKE GETTING IN THEIR
TAX FORMS ARE TO. BE SURE THAT
WE MOVED IT CONSOLIDATED BEEN
FILED IT. BIG YOU MIGHT BE
STAPLES BUT THE STATE HAD TEAM
DIFFERENT STATE. WE HAVE IT IN
ONE. THESE ARE UP IS. YEAH AND
THEN OPERATE I'M FOR FRIENDS.
NEARLY OUT FROM THIS. GIVE
MADAM CHAIR IN COMMITTEE. AT
KATHY LEE OUT WITH A STICK
OFFICE BUSINESS A THEN ON THE
ESCAPE POD. AT THIS GUIDED TO
THE WAY WE DO ISSUE VENDOR
PAYMENTS- AS MARIAN JUST READ
IT WE DO HAVE TO- FOR PROCESS
WE HAVE A CENTRAL US. I'LL ONCE
APPROVED AT THE DEPARTMENT DOES
RECEIVE A INVOICE THEY UTILIZE
THE INVOICE TO DETERMINE THE
SCHEDULE DUE DATE- THE DATE
THAT THAT THAT PAYMENT IS GOING
TO GET MADE. PREVIOUSLY WHEN I
SEE OVER THE CLAIM AND YOUR SCO
WOULD PROCESS IT AND THE
PAYMENT WOULD BE ISSUE. THAT
PROCESS HAS CHANGEDWITH THE
DEPARTMENT NOW IDENTIFYING THAT
DATE ON THAT WHEN THEY START
SETTING UP THE INVOICE. DATE
THEY POP IT THAT DAY. AND WHEN
THAT AND THAT'S GONNA DRIVE THE
ASH THE ISSUANCE OF THE CHECK.
IS NO LONGER ON A SEAT SO IF
IT. IS IN A. IT IS ON THE
DEPARTMENT TO KEY IN THAT
INFORMATION CORRECTLY INTO
OFFICE GAL AND SCHEDULE THAT
PAYMENT DATE OKAY THAT'S VERY
HELPFUL SO LET ME JUST- ASK A
COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS. AS I
RECALL THERE ARE PENALTIES. FOR
A INVOICE CURRENT INDUSTRY.
TIME NEARLY LATE THEY WERE
PAYING A LOT OF ALLIED IN THOSE
FINE- IS DOES THE SYSTEM ALLOW
YOU TO LOOK AT THAT AND TO SAY
HEY YOU KNOW GET. WE GET THE
MONEY SIR I'M IN MY CAN FRAME
ARE THE SMALL BUSINESSES AND I
WAS A DURING THE DAYS WHEN OUR
BUDGETS WERE SO LATE THAT. A
FIRST. SOME THIS IS. IN OUT OF
AND SO AT THE IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL I. FOR US TO TAKE OF
TRACK THAT JUST TO SEE WHAT TO
ARE A PROBLEM AND WHETHER THAT
TO IN A OF RESOURCE. JUST DOWN
NOT UP ON THAT PRETTY FUNCTION
SO I'M I'M OBVIOUSLY CAN ABOUT
THAT AND WE HAVE MADE SURE THAT
WE'RE WERE WE'RE REALLY.
MAINTAINING THE- OF THE STAY BY.
WE REALLY AREN'T THE DEEP HE
BUSINESS BUT IF WORD THEN GONNA
PUT AT RISK. BECAUSE WE CAN'T
CHECKS UP ENOUGH IT'S- YEAH SO
A QUICK EXAMPLE IT. CAN FOR
THAT CONTROLLER SHE GETS UP THE
CHEWING CALL ON HER THE VENDOR
PAYMENTS AS WELL. THE WILL GET
A CALL FROM THERE SO. THAT WAS
IT IF I TO LOOK. UNDER THAT YOU
WANT TO SEND OVER WE CAN
RESEARCH AS A WHAT INVOICES WE
HAVE WHAT THE STATUS OF IT
WHERE IS IT AT IT. IF IT'S THE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT IF IT'S
WITH A C. APPROVED. OR WHAT
THIS GET A DUTY IS ON THAT AS
WELL THAT EXCELLENT I WILL DO
I'LL GET ALL INFORMATION SO
THAT. AND TAKE GET IT AND-
HAPPY TO HELP. THANK YOU THANK
YOU- POP UP HERE AND GIVING US
YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY. UP
QUESTION. COMMITTEE YES SIR.
THANK YOU FOR WERE REACHING OUT
THIS YEAR A LITTLE BIT MORE
THAN BEFORE AND- MY INQUIRIES
ARE NOT WASTE CRITICAL OF VALUE
MORE RECENTLY REACHED OUT. IT'S
BASED ON A LONG AND SAD HISTORY
OF TECH APPLICATION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOES COST
THE STATE AND ITS CITIZENS.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. AN EYE FOR
VENDORS ALSO WHO HAVE MIND THE
STATE TREASURY FOR THEIR OWN
BENEFITS. NUFF SAID WITH THAT.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES THE CHAIR JUST
SPOKE OF THE SMALL. BUSINESS
LOW PAY. TRUST GOVERNMENT YOU
NAME THE AGENCY AND THERE'S A
LOT OF SLOW PAY GOING ON EVERY
SINGLE AGE BUT I THINK IT'S
TIME FOR MANY THINGS TO NOT BE
TOLERATED WHAT ARE THE
CONSEQUENCES IF THEN THE AGENCY
THAT DOES HAVE THE ABILITY. TO
SEE THAT THAT EXPERT IF THEY
DON'T DO THAT AND THEY CONTINUE
TO NEGLECT WHAT PENALTY DOES
ANY STATE AGENCY PAY IN A WAY.
UNDER THE PROMPT PAYMENT ACT%
THERE ARE PENALTIES THAT THOSE
DEPARTMENTS PAY FISCAL
PENALTIES OR WHAT SCHOOL
PENALTIES ARE THEY EVER LET DO
WE HAVE A REGULATORY OF HOW
MUCH. I BELIEVE THAT. BUT YEAH.
I DON'T I'M TRYING TO THINK OF
WHICH OF MY PARTNERS WOULD HAVE
THAT GOVERNMENT IT'S GOT A
NUMBER. OF KNOWS ME. HI AGAIN
IT'S AND ON THE DIRECTOR FOR
THE DIVISION AT THE DEPARTMENT
GENERAL SERVICES SO WE DO
PRODUCE A REPORT ANNUALLY OF
LATE PAYMENT. AT DEPARTMENT
INCURRED- IT DOES GET POSTED ON
THE DIGEST WEBSITE- SO THAT
GIVES INSIGHT INTO THE NUMBER
OF TIMES THAT WE HAVE HAD. A
LATE PAYMENTS- I'M NOT SURE IF
IT'S POSTED JUST YET OF FOR
THIS YEAR WE JUST GOT IT
THROUGH THE APPROVALS- BUT IT
DOES SHOW. DEPARTMENT THE ONE
TEN THE DOLLAR BUT IS THAT THE-
TEMPORARY EMBARRASSMENT WHICH
WOULD. THIRTY SECONDS THAT
DEPARTMENT. YES I'M A WHAT OF.
AND FROM THE TGS PERSPECTIVE I
DO NOT KNOW THAT THERE'S AN
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY SEEM
MANAGER THAT'S THE PROBLEM IS
IT DID SO EASILY IGNORED AND
GOVERNMENT. TO THE LARGER THAN
QUESTION AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE CLARIFICATION BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE DON'T
HAVE A CONSEQUENCES. AND THERE
ARE IT'S ALL MORE IMPORTANT NOW
AS WE ARE CONTINUING TO EMBARK
ON THESE BILLION DOLLAR
PROJECTS THAT THE- LEGISLATURE
THE SERVICE OF THERAPY. AND THE
SUPERSITE. YEAH I CERTAINLY
CONCUR WITH YOUR CONCERNS THAT
I'M SURE THIS WE'VE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT IT. AND AS WE PROCEED
WITH THIS PARTICULAR BUDGET. I
AM GOING TO SUGGEST THAT WE
WORK TOGETHER WITH ANALYST.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT PERIOD FOR
SOME VERY PRO SCRIPTED.
LIMITING THE LANGUAGE. DEFINING
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. WHAT
WILL GET DONE AND IN FACT WHAT
CONSEQUENCES ARE. AND FURTHER
THAT WE INCORPORATE COST
SAVINGS THAT WAS JUST SUMMARILY
DISMISSED A LITTLE BIT AGO WE
DON'T WORRY ABOUT COST SAVINGS.
EVERYONE OF THESE A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO P. WEISS I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE JUSTIFIED. AS TO
WHAT SEC THINGS WILL BE A BRING
OR WHAT EFFICIENCIES WILL BE
WROUGHT BY THAT. WHY BEING
PLACED IN THE BUDGET. BECAUSE
THAT'S A PERMANENT. OBLIGATION
OF THE STATE IN THOSE
POSITIONS. A VERY HARD TO GET
RID UP SO I THINK WE NEED TO BE
VERY PRESCRIPTIVE IN OUR
LANGUAGE HERE. ANOTHER ONE
WOULD BE DE MINING COMPLETION
WHAT DOES COMPLETION I MEAN
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S BEEN A PROBLEM
WITH OUR- OKAY GERMAN OF HIGH
TECH. PROJECTS THERE IS NO
COMPLETION IT JUST GOES ON IN
IN FOR NIGHT OF. SOME COMPANY
COMES UP WITH SOME NEW. THE
VICE SOME NEW SHINY OBJECT AND-
WHAT WE HAVE TO HAVE THAT NOW
THAT'S THE STATE OF THE ART
WELL OKAY GONNA HAVE TO HAVE AN
OVER OPEN AND- KEEP GOING ON WE
JUST KEEP CHASING THE NEWEST.
LOGY COMING UP EXCUSES THE WANT
TO BE HARD NOSED MADAM CHAIR
THIS TIME IN THIS BUDGET
FINALLY. IN THE STATUTE WE WILL
WORK WITH THE LEDGE ANALYST ON
THIS ON THAT PRO SCRIPTED
LIMITING AND CONSEQUENCES
WRITTEN AND STE SHAVINGS
CONSIDERATION LANGUAGE THAT
WILL MAKE US FINALLY. WORLD
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE RICH. WITH
THE TAXPAYER DOLLARS EMPLOYING
AND DEPLOYING ALL OF THESE
INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE. BY T.
PROJECT IF WE MAY THANK YOU
CENTER NIELSEN SENATOR DR SO.
THANK YOU WE SHOULD THE LA OWES
QUESTION WHEN YOU SAID WHAT
WHAT DID THE LEGISLATION IN TEN.
AND I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
PEOPLE SORT OF USE THAT FOR
SOME OF US COME LATER IS WHAT
WAS THE INTENTION AND AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE. RIGHT WHAT A
SPECIFIC AND I IMAGINE THAT A
LOT OF IT WAS NOT SPECIFIC IT
WAS JUST LIKE OKAY GO DO AND
THEN YOU START DOING THAT THEN
YOU FIGURE OUT THAT THERE IS A
LOT MORE TO IT BUT- MUCH AS YOU
CAN. THIS UNDERSTOOD. WHAT THE
AND WAS AND- AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE WAS A TIME FRAME. UP
IN A SHORT SUMMARY BECAUSE I
SORT OF LOSE THAT IN THE MIDDLE
OF A OF A LOT OF THINGS. I'M I
KNOW. FIRST YEAR WHEN THE ISSUE
CAME UP OF COST SAVINGS. OF IT
WAS A IT WAS A REAL QUESTION
MARK BECAUSE WE WERE- EITHER
NIELSEN SAID. APPROVING
ADDITIONAL STAFF FROM
DEPARTMENTS WERE FISCAL WAS IN
THE PROCESS OF BEING EMPLOYED.
YOU KNOW WE QUESTIONED WAS THIS
A TEMPORARY BECAUSE OF THE NEED
TO TRAIN BECAUSE OF THE NEED TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE WHICH I
UNDERSTAND WAS OF A BIG ISSUE
OF SO I DON'T THINK WE CAME UP
WITH A FINAL YES OR NO RIGHT
I'D IS THE STAFF GOING TO STATE
HERE FOREVER OR ARE YOU
TEMPORARILY TO TRACK. YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR WHERE THEY'RE GOING
TO BE COST SAVINGS AND AS I
RECALL THAT WAS NOT A VERY IT
WAS NOT A VERY CLEAR ANSWER
SIMPLY BECAUSE I SINGLE NEVER
WAS YOU WERE DOING THEN YOU
DIDN'T KNOW- BUT I DO THINK
IT'S A VALID TO SAY ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER. ISN'T IT THIS WILL
RESULT IN COST SAVINGS OR IT'S
NOT A LET'S JUST FACE IT LETS A
LET'S DIG INTO IT- BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND A LOT OF IT WAS A
ENGINE CULTURE AND I APPRECIATE
ALSO YOUR REF THIS STRAIGHT
TEAM. THE TEAM THAT WE ABLE TO
THESE ALL THE- BECAUSE I AM.
THAT WAS ALSO IS. LAST YEAR IS
HOW YOU DRESS THAN. THERE'S SO.
FROM THE SMALL SO YOU MIGHT
TALK ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT
MORE IS THIS STRIKE TEAM. OF
SO- SEE WHAT ELSE IN HERE. IN.
IF I MAY I'LL START AN
ALTERNATE OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE GS BUT IT A HIGH
LEVEL- WHAT IS AS I MENTIONED
WE SAW STRUGGLES IN A COUNTY
JOBS AND IT IS WE BROUGHT WAVES
THE DEPARTMENTS ON SOME OF THE
SMALLER DEPARTMENTS WERE IN
FACT- THE WONDERSTRUCK MOST AND
SOME OF THE BIGGEST MOST
COMPLEX ONES IT WAS THE EXTREME
YES IN SORT OF A HIGH LEVEL AND
SO DO. CONTACT THEM THIS WILL
SERVICES YOU SEE ADDRESS AND
THEY THEY RUN A CONTRACT A
BUDGET SHOP ACCOUNTING SHOPPERS
SMALL LIKE BOARDS COMMISSIONS
AND DEPARTMENTS I DON'T HAVE
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOUSE
AND THEY DO IT AS OF THE FOR
SERVICE SO WHAT WE FOUND TIMES
I GOT REALLY GOOD AT FISCAL. WE
SET UP WHAT. WAS. THERE FIGURE
IT OUT AND WE HAVE SOME OF
SMALL DEPARTMENTS LET'S LET'S
ENCOURAGE THEM COME INTO THE
FOLD THAT BURDEN OFF THEIR
PLATE SHIFTED TO BGS WHOSE
ESTABLISH SOME EXPERTISE HERE
AND GO FIND SO WE'VE BEEN DOING
THAT WITH THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORT THAT ONE OF THE PIECES
OF THAT WAS WAS EXPANDING THE
RESOURCES AND THEIR CFS SHOP
MEN AND BUT THERE'S A GROWTH
THE HAS TO HAVE AND HOW YOU GOT
A STAFF OF YOU GOT TO HIRE THE
PEOPLE THE NEGATIVE TRAIN THEM
UP. THEY DO. THE WAY. THEY CAN
THE- IT WAS WORTH. TIME WITHOUT
CABLE THAT THERE'S A NEED OUT
THERE FOR THE PARMA THAT DON'T
NEED TO CURRENTLY TRANSITION
THAT WERE IN THE NEED. BUT USE
SOME REAL HANDS ON ON TEACHING
THEIR PEOPLE THE ROPES SHE
SHOULDER HAND HAND AND SO THAT
WAS THE CONS OF THE STRC TEAM
IN THAT'S IN THE B. C. P. THE
MINISTER IS TO SAY AN I BELIEVE
SPEND THAT MONEY REGION AS WELL.
UNDER MOST OF. I THINK YOU YOU
ACTUALLY WILL COVER IT. THANK
YOU TO SAY I DO A- THE PROGRESS
YOU MAY. WE'RE IN A VERY PLACE
TODAY FROM WHERE WE WERE A YEAR
AGO AND I APPRECIATE THAT. AND
WHAT YOU'VE HAD TO GO THROUGH
TO GET HERE- I THINK YOU KINDA
GET BEAT UP. A LOT BUT YOU'RE
TOUGH. AND THESE ARE ALL
LEGITIMATE ISSUES AND QUESTIONS
WERE NOT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
DAY HEY HOW WOULD HAVE WHAT
HAVE YOU BEEN A FEW MINUTES TO
COME IN AND- SUMMARIZE IT ALL.
BUT I THINK YOU GET THE DRIFT
OF. WHAT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
SO THANK YOU. LET ME THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY
AND FOR GIVING AYE AYE I THINK
A VERY THOROUGH UPDATE ON WHAT
IS A REALLY COMPLICATED
PROJECT- AND IT YOU KNOW CHANGE
IS NEVER EASY I KNOW THAT WHEN
EVERY TELL DEPARTMENTS ARE
GONNA HAVE TO CHECK THEY DO
THINGS IT'S- AN EASY. AND I.
IT'S KIND OF IN IN AN- IN THE
MAKING IT EASIER FOR SOME OF
THE SMALLER. BUT DEPARTMENTS
THAT WERE THE FIRST IN LINE FOR
SITTING Q. I TO GET THROUGH AND
FROM MY POSITION IT SOUNDS
LIKE- WITH SO LET ME JUST SAY
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO-
DOCKED ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT INCLUDE THE
TRACKING OF THE MANAGEMENT
FUNCTIONALITY AND THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY THAT THAT INTERFACING
LEGACY SYSTEM. HE SURE THAT.
THERE IS THE SAME THAT IT'S
THAT'S BEING PRODUCED FOR THE
DEPARTMENTSRIGHT IN THIS NEW
SYSTEM- BUT ALSO- THIS
SECONDARY WAS THAT THAT THE
REMAINING DEPARTMENTS OPERATE
ON FISCAL AND WE I UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT MAY BE A DIFFERENT
PROCESS- AND YO YO THROUGH. THE
ANALYSIS OF WHERE THEY ARE IN
THEIR OWN SYSTEMS AND WHETHER
IT IT'S COST EFFECTIVE TO COME
TO COME ON BOARD AND I AS SOON
THAT'LL BE A REPORT IN THE
FUTURE THE END THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING AT THAT POINT AND WE
WILL BRING BACK LEGISLATURE
FOR. CONSIDER HIM BEFORE
PROCEEDING OBVIOUSLY RIGHT
AFTER. JUST WILL WORK YES OKAY
JUST ONE MORE QUESTION ON THE
DEFERRED DEPARTMENTS UP IS
THERE IS A FIX FOR IT. FOR
THOSE DO YOU KNOW WHAT
INFORMATION IS TO GET SOME. OR
ALL IS THAT SORT. WHAT THAT IS
THE IN OUR THAT WE ARE DOING
I'M NOW THAT WE'VE STARTED
THANK YOU FOR BUT THERE WAS NO
A NO I CERTAIN TIME NOW IT WAS
JUST HAD TO WE WERE THAT BY THE
TIME THE THOSE ENHANCEMENTS TO
THEIR SYSTEM. PLACE TENDS THAT
WE THAT WE CAL WOULD BE AN
ADDITION TO TAKE THEM. A
INSTEAD OF HAVING. THAT
SECONDARY. AT THE AND- EXEMPT
IS EXAM THERE'S LIKE A- NO. WE
THE- OR ANYTHING. THIS POINT
IT'S NOT. THE LEGISLATURE COULD.
THAT WHEN. THEY MAKE THAT. WHAT
LEFT ANY ELSE CORRECTLY TEMPLI.
RACKED THOSE ARE YOU KNOW THE
USED SYSTEM THE LEGISLATURE.
THE WHOLE COUNCIL ACTUALLY I'M
TO MY WE CAME IN ASKED LAST
YEAR THE YEAR BEFORE. THEY HAD
ASKED TO MEND OUR- AND WE- AND
A BC P. WAS APPROVED. WE ATE IT.
I'M READY. HE BROUGHT THE ONTO
OUR SYSTEM SO. IN THE THAT. I'M
SO LIKE THIS WE WOULD AND- NOW
WE ARE. THEY'RE NOT ON OUR IN
OUR FOR AN HOUR OR ANY. FROM MY-
THIS IS CAN I GET A LIST OF
EACH OF THOSE YES ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU. WELL MAKES EVERYBODY
GETS IT A COPY OF THAT LIST
CENTER NIELSEN YES THE LAST
OBSERVATION YOU KNOW WE-
NORMALLY GET THE WE'LL GET BACK
TO YOU RESPONSES. FROM AGENCIES.
FOR AND THESE HEARINGS OVER THE
DECADES AND I KIND OF MADE. THE
LEGEND OF MYSELF IN ONE HEARING
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WHEN I TOLD
THE AGENCY PERSON YOU KNOW YOU
FILL THE ROOM WITH WORDS
DELICIOUS WONDERFUL WORDS
THEY'RE ALL FALLING TO THE
GROUND AND TING LIKE SNOW. WE
DON'T NEED THAT AND INSTEAD OF
YOU GETTING BACK TO US IN THIS
BUDGET I WOULD LIKE TO SEE WEEK
GETTING TO YOU. AND SAYING THIS
IS WHAT'S GOING TO BE. INSTEAD
OF THE OTHER WAY AROUND YOU
TELLING US HOW IT WORK FOR YOU
WE WANT TO TELL YOU HOW IT WILL
WORK FOR US I THINK THAT NEEDS
TO BE A FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE
IN HOW WE BUDGET. PARTICULARLY
IN THIS VERY INSENSITIVE
INSENSITIVE AND SENSITIVE AND
COSTLY AREA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR NIELSEN-
AT I THINK IT THAT WAS
INFORMATION THAT YOU'LL GET
LESS- SO I WOULD APPRECIATE IT
IF YOU GET IT TO THE COMMITTEE
AND THEN WE'LL SHARE IT WITH
EVERYONE- WE I DO NEED TO ASK
IF THERE'S ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE. TO COME
IN ON THIS PARTICULAR ITEM TO
COME TO MAKE. IN NO MEANT THAT
CAN. OUR OUR- HIS **** OUR
REVIEW HERE TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY. VERY.
TO NEED ABOUT ON THAT. SO OUR
TASK TODAY MEMBERS IS TO- THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO
ADOPT ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDE TRACKING
THE PROGRESS OF THE CASH MEANT
MANAGEMENT FUNCTIONALITY
TROUBLE MOTION ON THAT. YES
SOME OF THERE IS THERE IS A
MOTION. OKAY AND- THE ROAD
PLEASE CENTER CABALLERO BY
CENTERING ELSON ENERGY DRAWS A-
VERY GOOD MOTION PASSES WE MOVE
ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES. WELCOME AND THIS IS
THE CONTRACTED FISCAL SERVICE
WORKLOAD INCREASE SO WE'VE HAD
A LITTLE BIT OF A DISCUSSION ON
THIS SO YOU MAY PROCEED. Q.
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS
INTEREST INVOLVED AGAIN WITH
APARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES- FOR
THE FIRST ITEM BEFORE YOU
CONTRACTORS. CONTRACTED FISCAL
SERVICES WORKLOAD INCREASE- THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING TWO
POINT TWO EIGHT MILLION AN
ONGOING EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
AND FIFTEEN PERMANENT POSITIONS
PROVIDE ACCOUNTING SERVICES FOR
NEW CLIENTS AND ESTABLISH THE
ACCOUNTING STRIKE FORCE THAT
WAS MENTIONED IN THE- PREVIOUS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. THE FOR
NEW CLIENTS WERE LOOKING TO
TAKE ON IT AS OF JULY FIRST
INCLUDE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
FAMILIES COMMISSION OTHER LIES
IN ITS FIRST FIVE. CALIFORNIA
YOU NEED COMMISSION. WOMEN
RELEASED FOR AND THE COMMISSION
IN PACIFICA. AMERICAN AFFAIRS
WHICH IS A NEW COMMISSION
CREATED BY THIS LEGISLATURE
LAST YEAR. NINE OF THE
POSITIONS WE DEDICATE TAKING ON
THIS FOR CLIENTS MITCHELL SIX
POSITIONS WOULD BE CREATED TO
PROTECT TO DEVELOP THE TASK
FORCE THAT WE'VE- WE'VE LAID
OUT IN THE PC P. WITH THE IDEA
BEHIND A TASK FORCE PROVIDE.
DIRECT HANDS ON ACCOUNTING
SUPPORT SERVICES DEPARTMENTS
WHO ARE IN NEED OF THAT- WHICH
COULD BE FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS PERHAPS THERE BEHIND
PERHAPS THEY HAD A LEAVE OF
ABSENCE PARTICULAR IN SMALLER
MEDIUM SIZED APARTMENTS WHEN
YOU HAPPEN RETIREMENT OR ONE OR
TWO PEOPLE KEEP PEOPLE OUT.
THERE COUNTY CAN GET STOCK AND
SO THE IDEA IS PRIDE NOT JUST
IN TIME ACCOUNTING SUPPORT
SERVICES- FOR THOSE DEPARTMENTS
IN NEED WHEN THEY BECOME
AVAILABLE. I CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. ANY
QUESTIONS OF. MISTER STURM FELL.
EXCUSE ME AT COMMENTS FROM THE
ALEJO HOLLINGER SOME OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE NO
PROBLEM I SEE WERE RECOMMENDING
APPROVING THE SIX POSITIONS FOR
THE STRIKE TEAM ON A LIMITED
TERM BASIS RATHER THAN ON ON ON
GOING IT SAYS THAT AS IS PUT BY
THE- ANY CONCERNS WERE THE-
POSITION JUST FOR. A TERM
RESOURCES FOR THE STRIKE TEAM
I'M IS THAT WE THINK THAT
THERE'S SOME UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
THE LEVEL OF WORK FLOW THAT
WILL MATERIALIZE BUT ALSO WE
THINK IT CAN CAN ENHANCE
OVERSIGHT OVER ON THIS CRITICAL
AREA AS WE'VE HEARD A LOT AND-
IN THE LAST FEW A FEW MINUTES
ABOUT FISKE OUT AND THE
IMPORTANT THAT PROJECT AND ALL
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE AND THE
PROP. ONLY ONE OVER AND OKAY
VERSES ARE COMING FROM HIDING
IT OF INDIVIDUAL CONDITIONS TO
DEPARTMENT HOW MUCH WE OF DID
YOU. AND SO WE THINK THAT IN A
COUPLE OF YEARS OTHER
DEPARTMENTS WILL HAVE A BETTER
SENSE OF HOW THESE RESOURCES
ARE BEING EMPLOYED HOW THEY-
INTERACT WITH THE OTHER
RESOURCES THE LEGISLATURE'S
APPROVED. I'M REALLY WHAT THE
ON GOING THE MIGHT BE IF ANY
BECAUSE WORK ALSO BETTER
UNDERSTAND PROBABLY THE
TIMELINE FOR BRINGING ON
ADDITIONAL DEPARTMENTS ON THE
FIFTH. SYSTEM VERY GOOD THANK
VERY MUCH THIS IS THEM THAT'S
RECOMMENDED OLD OPEN IS THERE
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS. OF THE
COMMITTEE. YES OULD YOU
RESPOND TO THE ISSUE OF THE
STRIKE TEAM IN LINE YOU THINK
I'M GOING. ALL RIGHT INTO. THIS
IS SO THE BEFORE YOU IT'S FOR
AS FOR PARTY RESOURCES CREE
DISTRICT ARE. HAS BEEN TODAY
THERE ARE DEPARTMENTS THE HELP
AND WITH THE AGING WORK IN THE
CARMEN FOR SINGS THE SERVICE
NOW WE DON'T SEE THAT ISSUE.
LEADING UP IN THE NEXT FEW. I'M
A CERTAINLY OF RISK AND
APPRECIATE IT WAS WRECKED ON
THE. IF I COULD FOLLOW ON THAT
ROAD. THE STE TEAM IS HOPING.
AT MAKE THE ADDRESS FOR DEPART
SAID OF HER CHALLENGES DE WHAT
HOW DO YOU THAT. I MEAN IN
TERMS OF THE FISCAL SO HOW DO
YOU SEE THAT MOVING ON INTO THE
FUTURE. SO THE IDEA BEHIND TEAM
IS WAY IS THE PRICE IN THE TWO
GETS REQUESTS FOR ON BASIS AND
SOME OF THE TECH SUPPORT WHICH
IS A PROGRAM FOR FISCAL PROVIDE
OTHER IS DIRECT A SUPPORT WHICH
IS THE TO FIND. OR A SEPARATE
STATE OF SYSTEM. IS IN A SINGLE
ORGAN. AND AT DO DIRECT ACCOUNT
WITH A DEPARTMENT SIDE AND- I
MY DISTRICT IN SERVICES I WE
WOULD PROVIDE ACCOUNT ON A
TEMPORARY BASIS TO THE- COUNTY
SPORTS A. B. C. SIDE BY SIDE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT. HELPING TO
TRAIN AND SYSTEM SOLVE.
WHATEVER ISSUE MAKING UP FOR
ANY HURDLE ABOUT. LAST TWO
YEARSAND I'VE ACTUALLY
PROVIDED SOME- WHEN WE HAD THAT
THE STAFF AND BAND WITH ON THE
SIDE AT THIS POINT WE FEEL LIKE
IT IT'S SOMETHING THAT DOES
REQUIRE A PERMIT NEED. SO THAT
DEPARTMENTS DON'T MIND BECAUSE
ONCE YOU BEHIND IT'S MUCH
HARDER TO COME BACK. YEAH ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. IF NOT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
INFORMATION- WE ARE GONNA BE
HOLDING THIS OPEN IS THERE ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THIS TIME. MAN AS I SAID
WE'RE GONNA BE HOLDING THIS ONE
OPEN SO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE WHICH IS THE CAPITAL
OUTLAYS JESSE UNRUH BUILDING
RENOVATION. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
TO ME MY NAME IS JASON KENNEY
ON THE DAILY DIRECTOR FOR REAL
ESTATE SERVICES HERE DID YES-
THIS PROJECT IS THE IS THE
FIRST OF THREE BUILDING
RENOVATION PROJECT BEFORE YOU
THIS MORNING EACH PROJECT IS A
DESIGN BUILD PROJECT. WHICH
MEANS TO FACE IS A PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA. AND THE ACTUAL DESIGN
BUILD FACE- BEEPER WENT. PHASE
FOR EACH OF THE THREE PROJECTS
WERE APPROVED PREVIOUSLY SO
WE'RE ASKING FOR THE TWO. AND
INTO THE DESIGN BUILD PHASE.
ALL THREE PROJECTS ROSS OF TEN
YEARS. PLAN THIS IS THE FIRST
ONE BEFORE IS THE JESSE UNDER
BUILDING FOR CONTEXT- IT'S THE
ONE OF THE TWO BUILDINGS IN THE
ROUND ABOUT RIGHT OUTSIDE THE
WEST WING OF THE CAPITOL AND%
PART OF. THAT RIGHT. HISTORY I
DON'T IN THAT IS MENTIONED IN
THE AGENDA WELL- THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT VERY- THOUGH
IT WAS BUILT IN NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHT OR SO IT IS A HISTORIC
BUILDING- AND DISCOVER THE-
OBJECT IS TO DO A COMPREHENSIVE
RENOVATION TO ADDRESS. ISSUES
INCLUDING LACK OF FIRE
SPRINKLERS. BUILDING IS
MISSING- SUFFICIENT EXITING
STAIRS- IT IS ALSO TRUE PLEASE
BUILDING SYSTEMS THAT WOULD BE
ELEVATORS PLUMBING CIRCLE UNTIL.
IN MECHANICAL. BUT TELECOMS
LIKE. I BUILDING ALSO SO.
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT WHAT TREASON
ISSUE SO I CAN'T BE MORE HAS
MATTER THAN WE HAD ACTUALLY AT
FIRST ANTICIPATED AS WELL
ADDRESSING PDA ISSUES IN OUR
OUR BUDGET REQUEST THERE WERE
THREE OPTIONS AVAILABLE- WITH
RESPECT TO THE CAPITAL FOUNTAIN
ONE- OUR BASELINE WAS DO
NOTHING TO- DEMOLISHED. FOR
THREE TO RESTORE ORDER READ THE
TAPE THE FOUNTAIN- WE- ONE THE
RECORD SAYING THAT WE HAVE NO
OBJECTIONS TO THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION RELATED FOUNTAIN
FOR THE PROJECT WELL. KIND OF
ANTICIPATING OF AND NOTING THAT
THE LA DOES RECOMMEND OR
COMMENTS IN THE- IN THE AGENDA
WANTED TO JUST TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT- THE COST FOR THE
PROJECT IT IS TRUE THAT-
COMPARED. TO NISHA ASSUMPTIONS
WITH PROJECT FOR LEGISLATURE IN
THE FIRST PLACE COSTS HAVE
GONE- THEIR NUMBER OF REASONS
FOR THAT ONE- WORSENING
CONDITIONS SO- THE TWO BIGGEST
ONES FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PROJECT. HAS MATT HANNAH WATER
ISSUE IN BOTH. BOTH IS WERE
SICK. WE'RE STILL EXPECT AND I
PROCESS IT'S- GOT TWELVE CENTS
HIGHER TO PRESSES. WE ARE ALL.
INCREASE CAN. THANK YOU. ALSO
ASSOCIATE TO INSTALL IN FACT IN
THE ONE OF OUR LAW SECOND PROP
AND RICHARD BOULEVARD WE HAD A
CON DROP OUT OF THE COMPETITION
OVER CONCERNS ON THE ELECTRICAL
ESTIMATES- ADDITIONALLY I THINK
IT'S A THE NOTE THAT FOR EVERY
DOLLAR THAT IT'S- IN THIS
BECAUSE OF COURSE OF COST LIKE
I MENTIONED IS AT ABOUT A
DOLLAR FIFTEEN A DOLLAR TWENTY
IT'S OF A CASCADE OF. WE HAVE A
TWO. PRETTY STRONG EFFORT I
THINK TO GO THROUGH AND AS
THESE COST WERE BEGINNING TO BE
FLAGGED AS OVER ESTIMATE FROM
PREVIOUS YEARS AS WE
INVESTIGATED- TO ATTEMPT TO GET
THEM DOWN WE LOOKED AT A NUMBER
OF VALUE HEARING THIS SIZE
IDEAS- ON EACH PROJECT WHAT IS
THE THAT'S A WE DID IT
SUMMARILY RICH JUST FOR THINK
TRANSPARENCY. A TOP AND THING
RENOVATION TGS HAS DONE THAT IN
PRIOR PROJECTS THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES THOUGH TO DOING SO
UNLESS THE BUILDING ITSELF IS
ABLE TO COME IN WITHOUT
CONSEQUENCE IN THE FUTURE- SO
YOU THE PARTITION MECHANICAL
SYSTEM IN YOUR- NATION ON THAT
THE AMOUNT. MISSIONAL COST AND
REWORK AND TENANTS- PACKS ARE
SIGNIFICANT- THINK ABOUT THIS
ROOM FOR EXAMPLE MOST OF THE
STUFF THAT YOU WOULD TOUCH AND
RENOVATION IS EITHER BEHIND THE
WALLS AND THE FLOOR TO CEILING
INTO ENGLISH. IF YOU'RE DOING A
BUILDING RENOVATION THE THINGS
YOU ABSOLUTE ONE HIT AND THAT'S
WHERE. THE MAJORITY OF THE
CALL. OUR BUT WE DID. LOOK
THANK FOR A WINDOWS ON THE
BUILDING THE ORIGINAL WINDOWS
WERE- WOOD FRAMED IN THE
SEVENTIES THERE WAS PROJECT TO
REPLACE THE NUMBER THE NUMBER
FAILING THEY WERE ALUMINUM
FRAME- WE COULD HAVE- ACOSTA
DOING A REPLICA TO GO BACK
THERE WOULD. WITHOUT ABOUT
MILLION TO THE PROJECT WE ARE
WAY X. WE REJECTED THAT OPTION-
THERE ARE- OTHER AREAS WHERE-
WE- LOOKED AT- POTENTIAL COST
ISSUES. AND REJECTED STYLE
ENGINEERING EXERCISES- ONE
EXAMPLE IS HVAC SO RIGHT NOW IN
THE BUILDING ALL THE MECHANICAL
SYSTEMS ARE DECENTRALIZED FOR
THE FLOOR- BRINGING UP TO THE
ROOF BUILDING COSTS MARGINALLY
MORE ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS- BUT THE WHAT IT SAVES
AND MAINTENANCE COSTS ENERGY
EFFICIENCY NOISE ATTEND. FOR
THE WAY THAT I GIVE THESE IS.
SAY THAT WE THE COST ONE UP WE
DID DEEP DIVE INTO THE IS IF
THERE'S WAYS WE COULD CUT COSTS
AND- WE FEEL OF THESE COSTS
ARE- APPROPRIATE FOR THE
PROJECT AND THE ONCE IN A
LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY THROUGH INTO A
COMPREHENSIVE RENOVATION THE
BUILDINGS. VERY GOOD- SHE- THE
DETAIL ABOUT WHY THE COSTS HAVE
GONE UP SIGNIFICANTLY DO YOU DO
YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION IN
REGARDS TO- WHAT. AND I
APOLOGIZE IN THE TOP OF YOUR
HEAD THAT THIS STANLEY MOSK
COURTS BUILDING. ON NOT THE TOP
OF MY HEAD SO THIS THIS THE-
LABORING COURTS BUILDING ACROSS
THE STREET- ON A COST PER
SQUARE FOOT BASIS WAS ACTUALLY
ABOUT WHAT WE ESTIMATED OUR
INITIAL PROJECT FOR WE USE THAT
AS AN ALONG. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE AND INTO THAT. AS THE
COSTS COMING BACK HIGHER.
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT BACK AND
CHECKED. PREDICT JACK ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE DISCOVERED
IS THAT RENOVATION WAS NOT.
COMPLETE SO- THEY DID ABOUT 75%
MECHANICAL WORK IN THE BUILDING
80% A LIGHTING THEY DIDN'T KNOW
INTERIOR BUILD OUT THAT HALF
THE ELEVATORS NAY TOUCHED ABOUT
TAP EIGHTEEN RESTROOMS.
EVENTUALLY BE A- BILL FOR THAT
THAT WILL DO THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THOSE THINGS IN THE
FUTURE. THE BUILDING ALSO HAS
SOME UNIQUE CHARACTERISTICS. OF
A SOME OF IT IS OFFICE SPACE
BUT THEY DO HAVE THE
SIGNIFICANT STORAGE SPACE THAT
RUNS UP TO THE BUILDING THE
CALL STACKS- AND IT IS A
MECHANICALLY SEPARATED. YEAH
AND SO YOU COULD AND THEY DID-
NOT TOUCHING THOSE SPACES AS
THOROUGHLY AS THE OTHER ONES
BECAUSE YOU COULD COME IN LATER
MAKE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS. NOW THE
BUILDINGS ARE YOU HAVE SIMILAR
AIR. RIGHT SIX. YEAH THE COURT
ROOM IT'S NOT INDIVIDUAL OFF
WHICH IS IN TERMS OF THAT
MECHANICAL AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
YOU'VE GOT TO PROVIDE SERVICES
TO THEM SO I GET IT OKAY. LA
THE DEPARTMENT SO MIGHT THAT
YOU'RE A LITTLE BIT WHICH IS
GREAT- WHICH IS FANTASTIC.
COMMENDATIONS FOR THAT ALL
THREE RENOVATION PROJECTS I'LL
JUST GO OVER THEM ONCE IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME RATHER THAN
REPEATING MYSELF. I'M BASICALLY
OUR RECOMMENDATION WAS TO HAVE
THE DEPARTMENT REPORT AT BUDGET
HEARINGS- ON DIFFERENT OPTIONS
LEGISLATORS HAVE AND- HE
REDUCING COSTS FOR THESE
PROJECTS AND THE REASON FOR
THAT IS THAT ONE WE NOTED THAT
THAT BUILDING PROJECTS WHEN
THEY WERE INITIALLY PROPOSED
WHICH WAS. THERE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETY. ANY
WE ALREADY IN OUR AND ASSIST
THEM TO BE BROUGHT. STE I
PROJECT THE STATE HAD
UNDERTAKEN I'M AND THEN THE
PROJECTS AS YOU HEARD HAVE
ENCOUNTERED SIGNIFICANT COST
INCREASES THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
IS FOR HONORABLY. AND THAT'S A
37% COST INCREASE SO IT'S QUITE
SUBSTANTIAL- THE OTHER TWO
BUILDINGS IT'S THAT LAST BUT%
STILL NOT INSIGNIFICANT 17%
BATES THAN AND RE SAYS. AT A
FOR IN PER. COST SO THE COST
ARE SEEING. ENOUGH AT WE
THOUGHT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WHEN OUT WEATHER SO COME IN IT
MAY WELL BECOME. THE SCOPE
THESE- RENOVATIONS I'M BACK TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE ARE
BUDGETARY CONCERNS- WANTED ME
LEGISLATURE UNDERSTOOD THAT
THERE ARE OTHER OPTIONS CAPTION
SAMPLE. OR SOMEONE. AND WEBER
OR TO YOU SERVE MORE SHELVE.
FORCE THAT HAS TRADE OFF IS THE
AS THE- DEPARTMENT INDICATE.
BUT THAT IS A BEAUTIFUL
BUILDING- AND I THINK DESPITE
THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW NOT
EVERYTHING WAS TOUCHED IT IT.
REALLY IS TO DO QUITE A GOOD
JOB WITH THAT BUILDING AND IT'S
VERY SIMILAR TO AND RIGHT AT
HIM. I THINK WAS CONSTRUCTED
WITHIN ABOUT A YEAR OR TWO OF
THAT BUILDING AND SO IN TERMS
OF LIKE. THE HISTORIC FEATURES
IN THOSEKINDS OF THINGS THERE
ARE SOME SIMILARITIES. SO THE-
NOT. HM PROJECT AND TELL AN OF
COURSE THERE'S A ITCH ACOSTA
INCREASES FOR THAT BUT THERE AT
ALL SOME CHANCE THAT WE'LL HAVE
A LITTLE BIT LESS OF A TIGHT
CONSTRUCTION MARKET RIGHT NOW
ALTHOUGH I THINK ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS OF COURSE ARE
CHANGING I'M PROBABLY BY DAY M.
BUT- BUT- WITH THIS PROPOSAL
FOR TOGETHER IT ANSWERED WHEN
WE ANALYZED. USED ANYWAY THAT
THAT FOR EXAMPLE THE LABOR VERY
VERY IMPACTED IN THIS AREA THAT
WAS AFFECTING SAYS WELL I'M AND
OF COURSE THINGS LIKE FINISHES
AND OTHER KINDS OF THINGS CAN
MAKE ON THE MARGINS ARE SO XIN.
AND I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THE LEGISLATURE. THOSE OPTION
AND ANSWER KNOW THAT HER IS
LOOKING TO MANY OF THEM THAT.
ABOUT OUR OUR COMMENTS. VERY
GOOD. ACTIONS THIRTY NIELSEN
MADAM AS TO ONE PARTICULAR
POINT THAT THE FOUNTAIN- AS I
CONCUR WITH THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION HERE AND I'M
PROBABLY ONLY ONE AROUND IT'S
BEEN HERE FOR. THE WHOLE
DURATION OF RESTORATION THE OLD
CAPITAL SIDE AND NOW THIS ONE.
BUT ONE OF THE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AS MAINTAINING THE
HISTORICAL HERITAGE. OF THE
INSTITUTION. WHEN THE CAPITAL
HERE WAS DEEMED EARTHQUAKE
VULNERABLE THERE WERE PROPOSALS
TO TEAR IT ALL DOWN AND BILL
TWO TWIN TOWERS THANK GOODNESS
THE TIME. GREATER WISDOM AND ED
HARRIS DO OUR HISTORIC HERITAGE
PREVAILED. SAME THING ABOUT THE
FOUNTAIN I THINK SIMILARLY OF
THE- SOLD AUTO THE- HISPANIC
OFFICER THAT'S OVER THERE NOW
THE KIND OF RAISE THEIR OWN
MONEY TO RESTORE THAT STATUTE
BUT MY POINT IS THAT'S A PART
OF THE HERITAGE AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT DOES NEED TO BE
RECOGNIZED AND CONTINUE TO BE A
PART OF OUR HISTORY SO I SPEAK
UP. THE FEDERATION THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE THAT'S-
HOW I FEEL ABOUT THAT
PARTICULAR BUILDING AS WELL I
AGREE WITH THE LA THAT. THAT
THE ACT COURTS BUILDING WAS
REALLY WELL DONE- YET IT AND I
DID HAVE A OPPORTUNITY GOING TO
THE PARTS OF THE BUILDING
THERE. WERE NOT DONE AND- AND I
UNDERSTAND WHY IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE BUT- BUT THE EN ROUTE
BUILDINGS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
INVITED THERE ALL THE TIME AND
THERE'S A LOT OF TRAFFIC IN AND
OUT OF THAT BUILDING SO YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE'RE
TAKING CARE OF THE ENTIRE
BUILDING NOT JUST PART OF IT.
SENATOR DR SO YEMENI. SINCE NO
QUESTIONS IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
ITEM I'D LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD. WHAT THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WOMEN AND
MEMBERS LA RESTATE SOME WITH
PRESERVATION SACRAMENTO AND
WAYNE DONALDSON WITH
PRESERVATION SOCIETY WE'VE
FORMED A GROUP AND WE'RE HERE
TODAY BECAUSE TGS HAS APPROVED
AND FARM PACKED REPORT AT
APPROVED DEMOLITION OF. AND DID
ITS REMOVAL UNTIL THEY GET
DIRECTION FROM THE LEGISLATURE
ON WHETHER IT SHOULD BE
RESTORED. FOR OVER TEN YEARS
THE FOUNTAIN HAS BEEN NEGLECTED
AND WE'VE BEEN TOLD OVER THOSE
TEN YEARS THAT THE FOUND WOULD
BE RESTORED IN THE FUTURE
POSSIBLY WITH THE UNDER A
BUILDING WHEN IT WASN'T
INCLUDED IN THE LIBRARY. OF
BERRIES BUILDING. AND WE
DISCOVERED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THAT THE UNREAL RENOVATION WAS
GOING TO DEMOLISH THE FOUNTAIN
SO WE MET WITH DHS. AND HAVE
LOOKED AT THE B. C. P. AND
RECOMMEND CHANGES TO
ALTERNATIVE THREE. TO PROVIDE A
CLEAR DIRECTION TO RESTORE THE
CAPITAL FOUNTAIN AND THE PLAZA.
ACCORDING TO THE SECRETARY OF
INTERIOR STANDARDS I ALSO WANNA
SAY THAT FORMER SENATOR PRO TEM
JIM MILLS CALIFORNIA
PRESERVATION FOUNDATION SAVER
HERITAGE ORGANIZATION THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO'S XIN COMMISSION.
AND THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS CENTRAL VALLEY AND
OVER A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
INDIVIDUALS ARE SUPPORTING THE
RESTORATION OF THE FOUNTAIN AND
I WE'RE ASKING YOU TO PROVIDE A
CLEAR DIRECTION AND I THINK
YOU'RE START OR DOES THAT.
AFRICAN TO BUILD WIND TUNNELS
AND WHO IS IN EXPERT ARCHITECT
IN RESTORING FOUNTAINS GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH I APPRECIATE
YOUR- ATTENDANCE HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU SIR MARKS ARE BURNHAM
CHAIRED AND SENATOR MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE.
AND ARE SENATOR NELSON I WAS
ALSO AROUND DURING THEIR TWIN
TOWERS FORMAL RECOMMENDATION SO
THANK GOD WE'RE- WE'RE STILL
HERE AGING WELL. FOR A STORE
HAVE ARE YOU MORE A LITTLE
BASIL SELF AND THAT'S WHY
REQUIRED OR PROTECT BY THE
SKITTLES IS BORN. I ALSO SERVED
AS A CALIFORNIA STATE HISTORIC.
PRESERVATION OFFICER SERVICE TO
GOVERNOR'S AT THAT TIME FOR
EIGHT YEARS AND I JUST
RECENTLY- I SERVED AS CHAIRMAN%
OF THE ADVISORY COUNCIL ON
HISTORIC PRESERVATION SERVING
TWO PRESIDENTS. AT THAT TIME
BUT I'M HERE SPEAKING AS A
PRESERVATION ARCHITECT FOR
SERVER RIGHT FORTY SECOND- OF
HAVING MY FIRM HERE IN OUR IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT WE'D ALSO AGREE WITH
PASSED RECOMMENDATION WERE FOR
QUITE HAPPY WITH THE WAY STAFF
HAS COME ABOUT ON OUR END TO
SORT OF BOB MIMICS BUT OUR WORD
SENATOR- NELSON IS SAYING IS
THAT I THINK ARE JUST BE A
TRAGEDY ARE NOT TO MOVE AHEAD
WITH THIS. WAS PARTICULAR
INVOLVED- WAS SERVER. CAN I WAS
ON THE BOARD AT THAT TIME IN
SAN DIEGO OUR WHEN WE SIR WHEN
WE SAVE THE HORTON PARK PLAZA
FOUND OUR WHEN ERNIE. OUR WHICH
IT CALLS HORTON PLAZA WHICH
KIND OF STOLE THE NAME FROM A
PART. OF THAT IRVING DO WHICH
IS ONE OF OUR MORE
INTERNATIONAL ARCHITECTS
DESIRING FOR THE OPENING OF THE-
HOTEL. I'M IT WAS INTERESTING I
THOUGHT WAS FROM BE DEMOLISHED-
THEY HAD HIRED ANOTHER
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECT COMMAND TO
REVISING TIRE HORTON PLAZA
TRANSCRIPT ATTACK OUR- AT THAT
TIME- WAS ALSO- CALLED THE
MOTHER BALBOA PARK AS WELL. ARE
KATE SEARCH AND SEE THAT ALL
AROUND- AFTER. WHICH IS AN
INVOLVEMENT- THERE ARE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF EFFORTS WE
NORMALLY SAVE A TOWN BUT WE
ALSO. LOOKED AT OF THE SIZE
RESTORING USING SOME TECHNIQUES
NOW FOR DOCTOR REVIEWS OUT FOR
INSTANCE WE PUT AN LED LIGHT
SOMETIMES PEOPLE THINK THAT
WHEN YOU RESTORE. PLAYING OR OR
IN THE CASE TROUT SENATE BIG
CLEAR THE WAY WAS WHEN IT WAS
BACK IN TWENTY EIGHT ARE LIKE
WE HAVE. TRUE WITH MORE. TO
MAINTAIN WHAT WAS AROUND A LOT
OF COPING ON THEIR HANDS TO BE
BUT THEY BE REFER IN TRYING TO
AGREE WITH THE SECRETARIES
TEARS START UPS FOR I ALSO
CURRENT WORKING IN SAN DIEGO
WITH THE RESTORATION OF THE
SEVEN FOUNTAINS THAT WERE PUT
IN A NINETEEN THIRTY ALL RIGHT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PACIFIC EXPO.
OUR FIRESTORM CORPORATE. ARE IN
PUTTING THAT IN A WAS TOMORROW
AND IN THE MIDNIGHT FIFTY AND
NOW. WE'RE READING ALL OF THE
CLASSES DOWNTURN PARKING AND
TURNING BACK THE PEOPLE SPACES
WHICH IS GREAT. ONE OF THE BIG
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE THIS
DROUGHT OF COURSE. THEY'RE NOT.
WE HAVE COME UP WITH A PLAN
THAT DURING THE TIMES WHEN
EITHER WE HAVE OUR GOVERNORS
ANNOUNCEMENT FOR THE ON THE
CITY COUNCIL SEND YOUR ANSWERS
THAT WERE OUT CONDITIONS HERE.
OUR IS THAT WE NOW HAVE A LASER
SHOW THAT WE WILL PRODUCE A
MERIT THAT HAVE SORT OF A
MISSED. OUR TO IT ON A WATER
MIST IS KIND OF A- THE MINISTER
NOT LOOKS LIKE. THE LIGHT THE
SINGING FOUNTAIN. BOTH MUSIC
AND DANCE. IT'S VERY STE
THIRTY. THIRTY CAPITAL. HAS
YEAH OUR TO SAY THE WE ARE WE
SUPPORT THAT ALSO WE FOUND OUT
THERE ARE FROM A- NEWSPAPER
ARTICLE THAT TO DIGEST WAS
QUOTED. AT THE LOSS OF WATER
DURING THE DAY FOR THE FOR THE
CAPITAL FRONT WOULD BE ABOUT
ONE TOILET FLUSH. ARE SO ARE WE
DON'T THINK THAT THE OPTICS OUR
MAIN CONCERN IN THIS CASE RIGHT
IT'S MUCH BETTER TO HAVE A
REALLY. WE HAVE. TO MAKE TO
REVERSE COMING TOGETHER- THAT
REALLY SHOWS WHAT THE UNIQUE
TRAIN IS. OF ALSO SACRAMENTO
JUSTIN'S RIVER CITY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE AND. IF I
COULD ASK YOU TO. BE VERY BRIEF
AT THIS POINT BECAUSE- THE
RECOMMENDATION IS A GOOD
RECOMMENDATION YOU MAY START
LOSING VOTES. THE MAKE IT SURE
THAT MY STATEMENT WAS ON BEHALF
OF. THE FORMER SPEAKER THE
ASSEMBLY WILLIE BROWN. AND THE
HONORABLE JAMES MILLS FORMER
STATE SENATE PRO TEM AND ALSO
THE HISTORIC RESTORATION
ARCHITECT OF THE CAPITOL RENT A
VIDEO. SERVED A ONE TIME AS THE
SENATE'S HONORS REPRESENTATIVE
ON THE CAPITAL RESTORATION
PROJECT. WE'RE DISTURBED THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES IS PROPOSING TO
DEMOLISH THE CAPITAL PLAZA
FOUNTAIN. IN THE THAT THE IT'S
AN UNJUSTIFIED ARCHITECTURAL
DISRUPTION TO DEMOLISH IT. WE
BELIEVE ALONG WITH OTHER
PRESERVATION GROUPS THAT THESE
ISSUES CAN EASILY BE CORRECTED
AND DOES NOT JUSTIFY
DEMOLISHING THE TERRIBLE
ELEMENT OF THE HISTORIC
ENVIRONMENT OF THE CAPITAL. AND
I CAN GO ON BUT JUST WANT YOU
TO KNOW THAT I'M HERE TO
REPRESENT THEM. AND THE- THE
PERSONALLY CALLED ME ON THAT
BEHALF THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE WE
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH YES SIR.
ADAM CHAIR SENATORS AT RICHARD
CAL AND I JUST WANT TO REPORT
THAT YOUR HISTORIC STATE
CAPITOL COMMISSION. IN ITS
BULLET REPORT WE ISSUE AFTER
EACH OF THE QUARTERLY MEETINGS
IN OUR JULY ELEVENTH IN OUR
OCTOBER TENTH BULLET REPORTS-
REPORTED THAT WE HAD CONSIDERED
THE ISSUE AND TAKEN THE
POSITION. WE FELT VERY STRONGLY
THAT RESTORATION AND
PRESERVATION WAS THE CORRECT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR COMMENTS
AND- I'M HERE TODAY SIR ANYONE
ELSE. BRIEFLY I'M- GREGORY VAN
AFTER I'M ON THE BOARD OF ABOUT
PRESERVATION SACRAMENTO AND
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S OUR POSITION
IS TO PRESERVE THE FOUND OUT
WHAT YOU MAY NOT KNOW IS THAT
MY WIFE ELLIE AND I VISITED
EVERY SINGLE OFFICE OF EVERY
LEGISLATOR THE CAPITAL AND A
PICTURE OF THE ONE WITH THANK.
AND EVERY SINGLE I'M SO. THEY
WILL OR THEY WOULD LIKE TO KEEP
THE FACT THAT EVERYBODY LOVES A
FOUNTAIN AND THEY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY WERE
PLANNING TO TAKE THAT OUT AND
STAND COMPLETELY THANK YOU S
MUCH APPRECIATE IT. THE
PICTURES ARE BEAUTIFUL BY THE
WAY. YEAH WELL THERE IS A
PICTURE. WE WERE. IN FUTURE WE
HAVE. AND I REALLY VAN ACKER
AND NOT ONLY DID WE VISIT WE-
ARE AMONG THE AUTHORS OF THE
SACRAMENTO BEE EDITORIAL
SUPPORTING THE FOUNTAIN WHAT I
WANT TO SAY IS HOW BEAUTIFUL
YOU A LOOK TODAY. THE CITY FOR
BEING. I'LL JUST SAY THIS YOU
CHOSE BEAUTY TODAY NONE OF YOU
SHOWED UP IN SWEATS ONE OF HE
WAS WOKE UP THIS WAY I MEAN
YOU'RE BEATING THE REST HAD TO
MAKE AN- THE YOUNGER OF US. CAN
ALSO I PUT ON LIPSTICK BEFORE I
PRESENTED TO YOU. WHY BECAUSE-
I CHOOSE BEAUTY. AS WE ALL DO
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTS
AND COMMENTS ABOUT THIS YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BEAUTIFUL
FOUNTAIN. THE OLD GIRLS ALMOST
A HUNDRED YEARS OLD. WHEN I'M A
HUNDRED YEARS OLD PRESENTING IN
FRONT OF YOU ALL HAVE TO DO
MORE THAN PUT UP LESS LIPSTICK
I'LL HAVE TO REALLY THINK ABOUT
HOW I'M GOING TO PRESENT
MYSELF. IN A WORLD OF UGLY.
YOU'RE MAKING THE CHOICE TO
BEAUTY AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT AND I APPLAUD YOU FOR IT
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE- YEAH WELL I WAS I WAS
GOING TO I WAS GONNA SAY THE
ILLUSION BUT I DID I REALIZE
THAT'S THE WRONG WORD BUT I
CHEATED YOU VERY MUCH I'M IS
THERE ANY. SEEING NO FURTHER.
TESTIMONY BRING IT BACK TO THE-
TO ADD THE DíAS AND SEE IF
THERE ANYMORE IF THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. CHAIR THANK YOU
THERE IS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CENTER HAVE AREA I CENTER
NIELSEN. RAZA YES. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU AND THAT AT THAT AS
YOU READ- INCLUDES LANGUAGE
THAT PROHIBITS THE DEMOLITION
OF THE FOUNTAIN SO WILL WILL
MAKE SURE THAT. DOCUMENTS AS
WELL I'M MORE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN WHICH IS
THE SECOND MEANT SACRAMENTO
REGION RESOURCES BUILDING
RENOVATION. THANK YOU I WILL-
I'LL BE BRIEF ON ON THIS
BUILDING THE NEXT ONE- THE
SCOPE IS VERY SIMILAR TO PARA
PROCONSUL THREE BUILDINGS THEY
ARE FULL BUILDING RENOVATIONS-
EACH BUILDING HAS SELECT
DIFFERENT DIVISIONS THIS
PARTICULAR ONE IS THE WORST
THING IT JUST PORTFOLIO
STATEWIDE- DOES INCLUDE A
COUPLE OF UNIQUE OF OUR LIFE
SAFETY DEFICIENCIES- AND SOME
SIZE. SHOES ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT. BACK TO THE GENERAL
COMMENTS ON INCREASING COSTS
THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT WE
FOUND AS WE WERE GOING FOR THE
PROJECT THEIR UNIQUE TO THIS
ONE- INCLUDING- WORSENING
STRUCTURE CONDITION- THERE ARE
SOME ADDITIONAL FIRE LIFE
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
FOUND FOR EXAMPLE. BY BUILDING
EVERY EXISTS THERE NEEDS TO BE
WHITE AND- ANSWERS GIVE SENSOR
THING FOR. SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL DEFICIENT PERHAPS
CORRECT TO A TO IT- ACCOUNT FOR
SPLIT THE COST INCREASE- OUR
APPROACH TO DEALING WITH THAT
ISSUE THE BILL. WOULD HAVE BEEN
DIFFERENT SIDE WERE COST ARE
COSTLY APPROACH. THE ARE A
NUMBER OF THINGS WE ALSO. VALUE
ENGINEERING ONE- SIMPLE EXAMPLE
IS THE SIDE. ON THE SIDE OF THE
BUILDING IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE
ADDRESSED AS PART OF THE
SEISMIC. SHIFT IN THE BUILDING-
WE THERE'S A NUMBER OF WAYS
THAT YOU CAN DO THAT A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT- COST. APPROACHES
DELIBERATELY PICKED NO THAT WAS
MIDDLE THE ROAD COST- BUT
EMPHASIZED LONGEVITY IN
DURABILITY TO AVOID HAVING TO
COME BACK AND DO WORK. FUTURE
AS WELL AS- THE SAME. SEX I'M
JUST AGAIN AN EXAMPLE OF CAR
WHAT WE LOOKED AT TO MAKE SURE
THESE COSTS ARE APPROPRIATE-
AND- WE WORK NOT COSTING THE
MOVE OR NOT. LOOKING THE BEST
THE BEST OF THE BUILDINGS WERE
WERE DOING THINGS THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON LONGEVITY
DURABILITY- AND BALANCING
FIRST. WITH LONG TERM
MAINTENANCE COSTS. NOTHING
ADDITIONAL DAD YOUNG. THIS
COMES IT OR WHAT WAS SAID
BEFORE- AT THE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. IS THERE ANY- MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE THAT COMMENT ON THIS
ISSUE. NINE I DO I DO HAVE ONE
QUESTION THIS IT WAS ALWAYS A
CONSIDERATION OF DEMOLITION
JUST THEM DEMOLISHING THIS-
ANALYZED IT WAS ANALYZED- THERE
ARE TWO REASONS WHY. IT WAS
REJECTED ONE- THE DEMOLITION
COST- AND- ADDED SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF MONEY IN TERMS OF IF
YOU WERE BE BUILDING THESE
ACTIONS WERE BUT IT SHOWS THINK
OF A MORE EXPENSIVE TO DO THAT-
THE OTHER ISSUE IS AT THE
BUILDING PREDATES THE CAPITAL
PROTECTION ACT AND SO- IT WOULD
ACTUALLY. NOT BE ABLE TO BE
REBUILT AS LARGE AS IT
CURRENTLY IS. IF YOU GET LESS
BUILDING FOR THE SAME. RIGHT
YEAH I GUESS I GUESS MY CONCERN
IS JUST RIGHT MY CONCERN IS ARE
WE GOING TO TAKE CARE OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE PLAGUED IT
WOULD FALLING WINDOWS IN CLASS
AND THAT KIND OF THING- THIS IS
THE BUILDING CORRECT AND THAT
AND THAT NO THE BUILDING WITH
THE SCAFFOLDING THE WINDOWS IS
A FOURTH IN ST ARMOR WE BUILT
OUT THAT'S ACTUALLY FIRST IF
THAT HELPS. WELL MAKE. I WAS
JUST CONCERNED ABOUT IF THAT
WAS THE ONE THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT TIME THANK YOU FOR THAT
SURE SHE DID SAY THAT THIS IS
NOT THE BUILDING OKAY SO IF
THERE ARE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
AT THIS RECORD STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AND THIS IS TO
IMPROVE ITS BUDGET IT.
ENTERTAIN THAT MOTION. MOTIONS
BEEN MADE UP PLEASE KALRA
CENTER CABRERA I CENTER
NIELSEN. CENTER DRAWS A- MOTION
PASSES UNANIMOUSLY MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN WHICH IS
THE SECOND IN A REGION GREGORY
BATESON BUILDING RENOVATION
YES- VERY VERY SIMILAR TO THE
PREVIOUS AYE AYE I WON'T GO
INTO MUCH DETAIL- I THINK-
AGAIN FORCING CONDITIONS- FOR
EXAMPLE NOT ONLY HAS THE EXTRA
WATERPROOFING SYSTEM FOR THE
BUILDING FAILED- THE RE DESIGN.
THAT AND DESTRUCTION IT WERE
THE B. TOOK IT APART AND SO
THERE'S BEGIN THIS BUILDING IS
THE SUBJECT- BUT WORSE
CONDITION BEFORE MIGHTY SAME
BIOENGINEERED. TEMP USE THE
COSTS. WERE TOP IN THE NUMBER
BEFORE YOU. HELLO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY OF THE ONE
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE ON THIS
OF. SEEING NONE IN THE. THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PROVE HIS BUDGET. I THINK VERY
MEASURES THAT MOTION- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CENTER CUT AREA
HI CENTER NIELSEN SENATOR US BY.
VERY GOOD PASSES UNANIMOUSLY
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN FACILITIES
MANAGEMENT DIVISION ELEVATOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND CENTERS- THE
PARMESAN SERVICES REQUESTING
FIFTY SIX POINT FOUR THREE
MILLION AT ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND- DOLLARS FOR HIGH PRIORITY
ELEVATOR REPAIR PROJECTS-
INCLUDE SEVENTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION FOR. BUILDING TWENTY
ONE- OVER TWENTY ONE MILLION
FOR THE RONALD REAGAN BUILDING
AND SEVENTEEN POINT FOUR
MILLION PER ROUND AND GEORGE
COMPLEX WHICH IS TWO TOWERS I
JUST GET A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW
IN HARRIS BUILDING WE HAVE
SEVENTEEN L. CARS- THAT ARE
ORIGINAL TO BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION- IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN SO THERE TWENTY
THREE YEARS- AND- CHALLENGES
THERE ALSO. MANUFACTURE WITH
ELEVATORS WAS SOLD IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE YEAR TO INSTALL
THEM TO FIND REPLACEMENT PARTS
IS BECOMING YOUR POSSIBLE. RON
REAGAN- BUILDING WE HAVE TWENTY
ELEVATOR CARS THAT ARE ALL
ORIGINAL TO THE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE SO THEY'RE ALL THIRTY ONE
YEARS OLD. ESSENTIALLY FULL
TIME. AFTER THAT TO FIX
MAINTAIN THIS POINT BECAUSE THE
LEVEL OF DETAIL AND KIND OF
PARTS TO PUT TOGETHER TO MAKE
THESE THINGS. ON A DAILY BASIS
IS REQUIRING THAT. AND IN THE
WRONG. BUILDING BUILDINGS
EXCUSE ME IF YOU HAVE. SIXTEEN
THE ONLY MODERNIZE LAST IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WAS
TWENTY YEARS OLD. THERE ALSO
SOME. FRIEDMAN BREAKDOWNS.
PEOPLE SO WE POSIT TO YOU ALL
FOR THESE PROJECTS ARE URGING
NOT JUST FOR THE GO OF THE
PUBLIC IN STATE EMPLOYEES IN
THESE BUILDINGS- BUT TO
MAINTAIN. THE SAFE BUILDINGS AS
WELL. VERY GOOD OKAY THREE OF
THREE ACCOMMODATIONS ON THIS
ITEM AT FIRST IS- AND THIS
REALLY APPLIES BOTH TO THIS
ITEM AND THE NEXT I MISSPOKE
COMMENTS ARE VERY SIMILAR BUT
AND THE FIRST IS TO THE
PROPHETIC FOR ALL THE MOST
JOINT CRITICAL PROJECTS AND SO
ON WE THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS ON
OF REAGAN PROJECT AS WELL AS A
FIRE ON. ABOUT COMMITTING
REJECTED RIGHT THE OTHER TWO
ALRP. AND THE REASON FOR THAT
IS THAT THOSE MIGHT NOT BE
WORTHWHILE PROJECTS ARE GOOD
PROJECTS I THINK WE AND WE JUST
SAYS- AND REALLY SORT OF AT THE
PUMP THE DEPART. BE FINDING.
PRIDE WHO. HIS PLEA RIDLEY ON
THE BILL RATES DE CHARGE FOR TO
ITS TENANTS ARE INTENDED TO
RECOUP THE COSTS OF OPERATING
AND MAINTAINING THE BUILDINGS
HASN'T ALWAYS WORKED OUT OF THE
COULD AND FOR EXAMPLE DURING
THE RECESSION- THAT UP. THERE
WERE SOME BUT- THAT THE STATE
WAS FACING AND SO ACCORDINGLY
THE DEPARTMENT HELD ITS RATES
VERY LOW FOR AND IT'S RENTAL
RATES ON THAT THAT WAS ONE
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR TO AT A
SIGNIFICANT WELCOME TO. AND I'M
SO WE UNDERSTAND THAT MEETING
WITH THAT OF THE LAST FEW YEARS
THAT THE STATE HAS PROVIDED
SOME ONE TIME AND THE
DEPARTMENT. I'M OUT OF THAT. DO
YOU THINK THEN ON BASIS THAT WE
SHOULD. BACK TO. A SITUATION
WHERE. REALLY WE'RE COLLECTING
SUFFICIENT FUNDS THROUGH THE
RATE STRUCTURE TO MAINTAIN
BUILDING ON GOING BASIS AND THE
DEPARTMENTS PLANNING FOR THESE
FUTURE NEEDS. SETTING ASIDE ANY
AS- AS AS A SO WE THAT I'M THAT
REALLY UNLESS IT'S ABSOLUTELY
URGENT- IT REALLY WE USE. THAT
SORT OF RATE STRUCTURE TO
DEFEND. I SECOND WE RECOMMEND.
VISUAL AND TO LIMIT THE USE TO
THE SPECIFIC PROJECTS THAT ARE
PRUDENT REASON FOR THAT IS THAT
UNDER TO COST ESTIMATES THERE'S
THAT ONE AND THE B. C. P. AND
THAT FIFTY SIX MILLION FOR
THESE LA. AT JACK'S. YEAH AND-
ARE MEANT. I'M FEW YEARS AGO
THAT ON THAT ON THAT WERE
ESTIMATED TO BE ONLY THIRTEEN
MILLION. SO WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE VARIETY OF REASONS FOR
THAT BUT- WE THINK THERE'S SOME
CHANCE THAT THESE PROJECTS
COULD COME IN LOWER INTO THAT
IT. IF THEY DO WE THINK THAT.
IT SHOULD BE BACK TO THE- AND
THEN THE THIRD IS THAT WE'RE
RECOMMENDING REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT'S REPORT ON ITS LONG
TERM PLANNING FOR MAINTAINING
BUILDINGS THEY'VE- IDENTIFIED A
VERY SUBSTANTIAL BACKLOG. OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE- AND SO
AGAIN WE DON'T THINK THAT. IT'S
REALLY SUSTAINABLE THING FOR
THE STATE EVERY YEAR WE DONE
ANYTHING SINCE MAYBE TWO DOZEN
FOURTEEN FIFTY. RECALLING
CORRECTLY PROVIDED THESE ONE
TIME DEFERRED INSIDE. WE DON'T
THINK THAT THAT'S THE STATE TO
DO AN ON GOING BASIS. TO WORK
TO COME UP WITH A- SOLUTION. WE
THINK. YOU KNOW IN IN YOUR- TRY
TO. READ AND- THE DEPARTMENT
FOR THESE JACKSON MAINTAIN
THEIR AS IF LEVEL. AND I'M AT
RESPONSE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
SERVICE. YEAH I'VE I THINK WILL
POINT OUT- TWO MANY THINGS
PERSONS THAT WE FEEL VERY
STRONGLY THAT ALL THESE
PROJECTS TO BE COMPLETED AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE- WE'VE ALREADY
STARTED THE DESIGN WORK ON. IT
THE FUND'S CURRENT BEAVER
MAINTENANCE THAT SAID- IT'S
THE- FOR THE DAY THE OPERATION
THE BUILDINGS WERE NEVER
INTENDED TO CAUSE MASS TO SCALE
CHECK SUCH AS IS AND WE WERE TO
BUILD INTO THE RATES. NOW
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO. ANY ON
THE DOLLAR TO COVER COST NOW WE
WOULD BE SITTING ON A GREAT
CASH THAT I'M NOT SURE THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD APPRECIATE
QUITE FRANKLY WITHOUT HAVING
MUCH MORE ROBUST DISCUSSION ON
FUNDING MECHANISMS POTS DREAMS
SO. THESE PROJECTS NEST JERRY
AND BECAUSE THEY'RE FAR EXCEEDS
OUR TOTAL ANNUAL BUDGET FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FROM
ENTIRE PORTFOLIO. OKAY THIS IS-
AN OPEN THE ISSUE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO MAKE THE COMING ON
THESE. ON THIS ISSUE SEEING
NONE AT QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THE QUESTIONS SO
CURRENTLY THE ELEVATORS ARE
FUNCTIONING- NOT FUNCTIONING-
AND EVERY CONCERN IS YOU
PROBABLY DO ABOUT NOT HAVING
FUNCTIONING ELEVATORS IN THE
BUILDING. EARN THEIR IN VARIOUS
STATES QUITE CANDIDLY AND I DO
NOT HAVE IN FRONT OF ME THE
EXACT NUMBERS OF WHAT'S HOW
MANY ARE FUNCTIONING TODAY WHAT
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS ONE GOES
UP AND ONE GOES DOWN AND ALL
FOUR OF THESE BILLS. WE HAVE
RARE. EARLY FOLKS. ELEVATORS OR
JUST NOT ENOUGH ELEVATORS TO
SERVICE THE FOLKS COMING UP AND
DOWN THE BUILDING SO IT IS A
HUGE. SERVICE ISSUED TO BOTH.
AND CANDIDLY. BOYS ROBERT
WORKING THESE BUILDINGS AND-
HAS BECOME A CHALLENGE AS WELL.
BECAUSE CONCERT AND- I'M SURE
YOU WILL GO FOR WITH THIS- WHAT
IS THE TIME. SO THEY WOULD BE
AS I MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
REMARKS ALL THREE OF THESE
PROJECTS WE HAVE UNDER SIGN UP
THE GOAL WOULD BE IF APPROVED
BY BOTH LEGISLATION ON THE
AMOUNT THAT WE WOULD START
CONSTRUCTION ON ALL THREE OF
THESE PROJECTS IN THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR. WE WOULD BE IN
CONSTRUCTION. THIS FISCAL IN
WHICH THE DOLLARS WERE
APPROPRIATE. SO MEANWHILE
THEY'RE STILL MEANWHILE THE
WORST WE'RE STILL WORKING THEIR
DATA SERVICING THEM CORRECTLY.
SO THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
HOLD OPEN THE SYSTEM
RECOMMENDATIONS OR WILL DO THAT
AND THAT TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
AGAIN- ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN IT
THE SAUDIS MANAGEMENT DIVISION
FIRE ASSIST. ME IN ADDITION TO
THE ELEVATOR MADE ITS BCP WE
HAVE A SECOND PC PEACE DAY FOR
YOU THE REQUEST TWENTY THREE
POINT SIX MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. FOR WHAT WE WOULD
CONSIDER SOME HIGHS PRAIRIE
FIRE LIFE SAFETY REPAIRS AND
BUILDING PROCESS IT INCLUDES.
IN BROWN'S BUILDING SAN
FRANCISCO THE VAN NUYS BUILDING
IN VAN NUYS. FROM JUST BILL IN
SACRAMENTO THE SECOND I BRING
COURTS BUILDING HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND THEN FOR FTD
CAMPUS BUILDINGS ACROSS THE
STATE. AHMED ANSWER A QUICK
MONIES THE GOOD HELLO. WE
DIDN'T RAISE ANY CONCERNS WITH
US BECAUSE WE DID I FEEL THAT
THEY WERE VIRGIN PROJECTS. VERY
GOOD- IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE THE-
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE
ITS BUDGET. FOR THE MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CENTER
CABALLERO AYE NIELSEN AYE RAZA.
VERY GOOD THAT PASSES
UNANIMOUSLY MOVING ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN WHICH IS THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE SERVICE
EQUIPMENT ASSESSMENTS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- JUST A AS A-
INTRODUCTORY REMARK WE'RE
COMING BEFORE YOU SAFE OR WHAT
IS YOUR FOR OF A FIVE YEAR PC.
AM I WILL. CONSIDER NAY MAY
REMEMBER. FIVE BUT WITH A ONE
TIME ASK FOR FIVE YEARS OF
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM AND
SO- BOTH OF THESE ABOUT HOUSES
REQUESTED THAT WE COME BACK
ANNUALLY ON THIS ITEM SO THIS
IS FOR QUESTION TWENTY POINT
FOUR MILLION EN IN TOTAL. SLASH
OF FOR. OUR FUND YOUR FOR THE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT PLAN.
BREAKS DOWN TO FIFTEEN MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND THAT WOULD GO
TO SERVICE ROLLING QUANTITY
YES. AND THEN IT IS. POINT FOUR
MILLION IN AUTHORITY THAT WOULD
BE THE AND PAIRED WITH. FUNDS
FROM OF CASH FROM. WE PARTNER
WITH THE DISEASE INSULATIONS
AND I'VE NANCY AND HER WITH ME
TODAY WAS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF OUR STEAM BILLY PROGRAM CAN
ANSWER A QUESTION. I'M COULD
YOU. JUST HAVE A REAL QUICK
QUESTION- AND IT IS OCCURRED TO
ME THAT IS THERE ANY REASON
THAT WE DON'T USE YOUR G.
FUNDING FOR THIS. OR IS THIS IS
THAT YOU'RE THE FUNDING ARE WE-
PROHIBITED FROM USING IT FOR.
TOP PART OF MY COLLEAGUES
ANSWER TO ANSWER THE QUESTION.
TED RAN A PERMANENT FINANCE
HISTORICALLY- EVEY
INFRASTRUCTURE POP PROJECTS
HAVE NOT BEEN FUNDED USING THAT
EACH YEAR AT THEY'RE ALSO A
NUMBER OF ON GOING PROGRAM SAID
THAT USING. THAT USE FUNDING
FROM THE G. AND IS THERE BUT NO
PRO. JUST WITH. DENNIS I WOULD
I WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT OKAY HISTORICALLY
THAT'S- THE CASE OKAY. THIS
WILL. HELLO SO IF I MAY I START
YOUR STANDING IS THAT THERE'S
NO PROHIBITION ON USING TEACHER
AT IN FACT THAT I THINK THIS IS
CERTAINLY ALLOWABLE USE FOR
JEERED. RAF THERE'S ALSO THEIR
FUNDING SOURCE WE'VE IDENTIFIED
A PATH COULD POTENTIALLY BE-
AVAILABLE ALTHOUGH OF COURSE
THERE ARE TRADE OFFS WITH THOSE
I THINK THE OTHER ONE WITH THE
ALTERNATIVE AND RENEWABLE
FILLING VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY
PROGRAM. BUT AGAIN. FIND AND
THEIR TRADE OFF THE POOREST AND
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THE
LEGISLATURE WANT TO CONSIDER
WITH ITS FUNDING PACKAGE BUT G.
GIRAFFE- I THINK IT'S CERTAINLY
AN ALLOWABLE USE HERE'S- WHAT
THAT. THING YOU KNOW IF GENERAL
DISK. AND OR OTHER PRIOR. THANK
POTENTIALLY. THANKS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT. IT IS THERE
ANY MEMBER MEMBER. PUBLIC THAT
LET WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS ISSUE. SEEING
NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR RUSSELL. I'M
OUR TASK TODAY'S TO HOLD THIS
OPEN SO WE WELL. AND MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN WHICH IS
THE WORK LED WORKLOAD
ADJUSTMENT AND POSITION
TRANSPARENCY BCP. I'M SORRY.
I'D JUMP AHEAD. EIGHTEEN SORRY
I CALIFORNIA PHARMACEUTICAL
COLLABORATIVE LOCAL OUT REACH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- THIS
PIECE PEAS RIPPED THE PARMESAN
SERVICES QUESTING SEVEN OR
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND AND IT
ALL ON THE FORTY. FOR THREE
YEARS- FOR AND FOR PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE
WORKLOAD FOR THE STATE WHAT
PHARMACEUTICAL PROGRAMS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OUTREACH PROJECT AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA. WITH
DATA. I DIVISION ANGELA SHELLED
ANSWERING QUESTIONS ME. VERY
GOOD DID YOU HAVE A PRESENT
HERE YOU WANT TO GIVE I DO JUST
HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL A MY I
THINK THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL CASE THESE BEEN. MORE A
SHOVEL TO. US A THE CAL
PHARMACY COLLABORATIVE- WHICH
IS A PART OF THE- STATEWIDE
PHARMACEUTICAL PROGRAM THAT IS
HOUSED AT TGS- THE
COLLABORATIVE WAS ESTABLISHED-
BACK IN- TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
AS A MECHANISM TO. I HAVE STATE
DEPARTMENTS COLLABORATE ON HOW
TO CURB- INCREASED COSTS OF
PHARMACEUTICAL SUCH AS THE
APPETITE IT. RUG THAT WHAT. AT
TIME- AT THE COLLABORATIVE- IN
THIS FORMAT BEGAN IN JUNE OF
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE HAVE
SEVERAL STATE DEPARTMENTS THAT
PARTICIPATE IN THIS
COLLABORATIVE AND DEEP AS HIS
WRIST WELL FOR STAFFING THE
COLLABORATIVE FOR OR USING IT
FOR TAKING NOTES. WE ALSO HAVE
COMMITTEES THIS CALL OPERATIVE
THAT OF ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
POLICY- ESTABLISHED ANY
POLICIES LOOKING AT A CONTRACT
CONSULT ASIAN. I'M AS EQUAL OUT
REACH I'M AND THEN ADDITIONALLY
THE SHE WENT OF THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER ON THE CAME OUT AND SHE
OF LAST STAFF ALSO BE READ. AND
WITH ALL OUR THREE PC IO
SPECIFIC. YES TWO CAN YOU WORK
WITH THIS. ON ESTABLISH AN
ADDITIONAL ACTIVITIES RELATED
TO IMPLEMENTING IMPLEMENTING
BOTH PURCHASING ON BEHALF
STATING. HELLO WE SPECIFIC
ANSWER TO THE PROPOSAL THAT WE
DO KNOW THAT THE ISSUES RAISED
BY STAFF ARE CERTAINLY
REASONABLE. IS THERE ANY MEMBER
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO REST
THAT COMMITTEE ON THIS ISSUE.
SEE AND A BRIEF BACK TO- THE
COMMITTEE AND I A I HAVE TO SAY
THAT I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED
WITH THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
MORE. STAFF IN PARTICULAR ABOUT
THE- SECOND. AND IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT WE MAY NEED THIS THIS IS A
HOLD OF OPEN ITEM BUT WE MAY
NEED LANGUAGE THAT- AT AND MY
EXPERIENCE. WITH GO COUNTY
JAILS IN PARTICULAR IS THAT.
THERE ARE VERY FEW MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE- AND- THE ABILITY TO
OVER MEDICATE IS. VERY AND WHEN
YOU'VE GOT A POPULATION THAT
YOU WANT TO CONTROL AND THE
POSSIBILITY OF GETTING
PSYCHOTROPIC DRUGS- AND- I'M
WORRIES ME I THINK WE SAW WE'VE
SEEN THAT IN YOUNG CHILDREN AS
WELL AS THEY HAVE THE DRUGS IN
USED. PROBABLY ARE USED YOUNG
KIDS IS A WAIT THERE AND- WHAT
WHEN I WAS YOUNG WAS JUST SEEN
AS HYPERACTIVE ACT ACT EXPECTED
ACTIVITIES SO- I THIS LIKE I
SAID THIS IS AT A HOLD OF OPEN
ITEM BUT- TO. SAY THAT I'M
CONCERNED. TERMS OF. THE AXE.
SO IT MAY BE ONE ANSWER ASK AND
ANSWER THAT IT'S I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION I JUST RAISING IT IS
AN ISSUE. I CAN'T WRITE A
LITTLE BIT TIONAL A INFORMATION
WITH RESPECT TO THE- THE STATE
COUNTY TASK FORCE THAT WOULD
INCORPORATE THE POPULATIONS
GOALS RIGHT PART OF EFFORTS-
THAT WERE IN A FIGHT IN A
WORKING THROUGH THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER ACTIVITIES. WHAT'S THE
NEED TO HAVE BEEN CREATION WITH
LOCAL JAILS BETWEEN. OF THE
STATE. ELITE THE STATE SPITTLE.
THE LOCAL CHAIR IN IN WHICH
THERE IN WHERE YOU HAVE THE
SAME. PATIENTS GOING THROUGH
ALL OF THOSE FACILITIES- SO
PART OF THAT- WE HAVE NOT
GOTTEN THAT FAR INTO- THE
CONCEPT OF WHICH SPECIFIC
DRUGS- AND WHAT ARE THE MAIN
ISSUES WE CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH. HOW FORCE THAT INCLUDES-
SOME OF THE JAILS TO KIND OF
IDENTIFY AND PROVIDE DATA TO D.
G. S. ON WHAT THEIR OPERATIONS
ARE WHAT DRUGS THEY SEE AS
MAYBE A BENEFIT THE DG ASK A
CONTRACT ON BEHALF. I'M QUITE.
FAR INTO THE ADA VERY GOOD IT I
JUST KNOW THAT- THAT EVEN WHEN
INDIVIDUALS ARE. TAKEN INTO THE
JAIL. PRESCRIPTION THE COUNTY
JAILS WILL NOT KILL IT UNLESS
THEY HAVE A DOCTOR THAT'S GOING
TO CONFIRM THAT THAT
PRESCRIPTION SHOULD FOLLOW THE
INDIVIDUAL AND SO I'D BE TO
TEND TO GIVE THE CITY THE
COUNTY HAS TO DECIDE IT IS IT'S
GOING. THE STATION WITH THEIR
BE AT. HE N. DONE BY A DOCTOR
THAT'S QUALIFIED TO BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE THAT THAT PARTICULAR
MEDICATION SHOULD BE GIVEN TO
IN. I APPRECIATE THAT NECESSITY
OF FOLLOWING HAVING THAT DRUG
FOLLOW BECAUSE SOME OF THE
PSYCHOTROPIC DRUGS ARE ON. IT
IS SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES IF YOU
TAKE THEM OFF WITHOUT ANY-
WEANING OR WORK OUT THE
APPROPRIATE- REDUCTION IN A
PRESCRIPTION SO I AM JUST
CONCERNED THAT WE BE COGNIZANT
OF THAT IN AND HAVE SOME GOOD
PARAMETERS AROUND. THE CITY TO
BE ABLE TO GET- THE MEDICATION
TO THAT END SO THAT'S JUST MY
CONCERN. SO MAYBE MAYBE THAT
THAT A FOLLOW UP TO WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOME. SO THIS IS
THE HOLDER OVER ITEM YES S.
CENTER DRAWS A- MANAGER I Q.
KERR I AM CONCERNED ABOUT US
MAYBE BE IN THE POSITION. BLAME
A GREATER USE ARE HOT. OF THIS
KIND OF MEDICATION AS ONE
EXAMPLE THAT THAT YOU GAVE SO
UP I'M NOT SURE ABOUT THIS OF
THE JAIL TASK FORCE AND- YOU
KNOW. IT'S PURPOSES GOALS AND
HOW IT'S FUNCTIONING THERE IS
AN ISSUE HERE- IF THERE'S A
BUDGET ISSUE AND THEN THERE'S A
POLICY ISSUE OF THE USE OF THE
DRUG. BUT THEY SEEM TO BE FULLY.
SO HOW DO WE GET TO THE TO THE
BOTTOM OF HOW DO WE GET THE
ANSWERS. ABOUT OUR CONCERNS OF
THIS TASK FORCE HAS BEEN SET UP
SO DTS WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE PURCHASING END OF IT ONLY
WE WILL NOT BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE POLICY PIECE I'M AND SO IN.
IN THAT WE WILL ENGAGE.
PRACTITIONER THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE MAKING THOSE
DECISIONS SPECIFIC TO THE DRUGS
THAT ARE PURCHASED- WE AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND HAVE A FORMULA
COMMITTEE. AT A FOR THE STATE
BUYS THAT WE MAKE THAT
INCORPORATES PRACTITIONERS
PHARMACISTS- OTHERS THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR DETERMINING
WHAT THE DRUGS DO WHAT THE
EFFICACY OF THE DRUGS ARE ALL
OF THOSE IT. IS THAT ARE
RELATED TO SOME OF YOUR POLICY
CONCERNED YES TO. THE DISTANCE
MAKE THE DECISIONS ON ON TO THE
DROP THAT THE PARK. HAVE
DETERMINED ARE THE- UGGS TGS GO
PROJECT IS THE OF THE STATE. T.
WE WERE ENVISION AGAIN THAT THE
TASK FORCE HAS GOTTEN OFF THE
GROUND YET BUT WE WOULD
ENVISION A VERY SIMILAR
STRUCTURE TO SOMETHING LIKE
THIS IN WHICH TGS NOT MAKING
THOSE POLICY DECISIONS ON. OUR
DRUGS ARE APPROPRIATE IN THESE
INSTANCES WELL THAT'S EXACTLY
MY CONCERN- IS THAT BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT THIS TO BE- SILO.
YOU KNOW THE ISSUES TO BE SILOS
THAT THIS IS WE'RE JUST GOING
TO. BE THAT WE'RE WE'RE THE
ONES IN CHARGE OF BUYING. THE
DRUGS THAT WE WANT NOBLE GRADE
WE YOU KNOW WHAT IS A GOOD
PLACE FOR YOU TO BE. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME. POSITION OF-
APPROVING THIS UP. WITHOUT
BENEFIT. SEE DISCUSS SO I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS HOW AND WHERE DO
WE HAVE THAT POLICY DISCUSSION
WHICH IS VERY MUCH CONNECTED TO
OUR A BUDGET ISSUE. I DON'T
KNOW WHO CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. AND WE MEAN WE MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO TODAY BUT WHAT I
THINK- AND CERTAINLY ASSIST YOU
JUST WANNA BE CAREFUL THIS NOT
STEP OUT OF OUR POLICY AREA OF
EXPERTISE BUT BIG WEEK FOR
CERTAINLY FOLLOWING UP WITH. ME
DEFINITION TO DISCUSS THE AND
HELP FIGURE CAN ABOUT THE NEXT
OF I THINK THAT MIGHT BE
APPROPRIATE BECAUSE THIS THIS
MAY BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD GO
EITHER. YOUR THROUGHOUT. HEALTH
TERM OF AN ANALYSIS OF WHAT
KIND OF. WHAT WHAT ELSE WE NEED
TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT- OUR
CONCERNS THE POLICY CONCERNS WE
HAVE ARE TAKEN CARE OF SO I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I. WE ARE
GOING TO HOLD THIS ONE. THIS
ITEM OPEN AND WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO KIND OF REVISIT
THE DISCUSSION MOVING ON TO THE
SECRETARY GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
AND OUT ALL YOUR WORK. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
NINETEEN WHICH IS THE WORKLOAD
ADJUSTMENT AND POSITION
TRANSPARENCY. WELCOME THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND FELLOW MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME'S
JUSTIN OUR DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
FISCAL POLICY ADMINISTRATION
AND OPERATIONS YOU CAN SEE WITH
ME IS THE STATE'S CHIEF DATA
OFFICER TôI BONE GROWTH THE
PROPOSAL THAT YOU HAVE BEFORE
YOU IS ONE RELATED WORKLOAD
WITHIN THE A- AND C. AS WELL.
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WE ARE
REQUESTING IS THREE NEW
POSITIONS INCLUDING ASSOCIATED
COSTS AS WELL AS ANY ASSOCIATED
INCREMENTAL COSTS FOR THE RE
CLASSIFICATION OF TO EXISTING
POSITIONS ALONG WITH AN
ADJUSTMENT FOR LEASE COSTS
RELATED TO OUR AGENCIES-
PENDING MOVEMENT OUT OF THE
BUILDING- AS IT IS GETTING
PREPARE. D. G. S. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FOR YOU
THE GOAL OF THIS PROPOSAL WAS
TO BE TRANSPARENT WITH HOW
THINGS HAVE BEEN OPERATING
WITHIN THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY OVER THE TIME
AGENCY IS. PARTICULARLY BEEN
BORROWING POSITIONS FROM
POSITION OF FROM OUR DEPARTMENT
THAT REQUIRE TRUST AND WE
WANTED TO CLEAN UP THAT
PRACTICE IN ORDER TO GET
EVERYTHING ON TO OUR BOOKS SO
THAT YOU CAN SEE WHAT THE TRUTH
RATING COST ABOUT AGENCY YES.
THE WAY WE CAN STOP BACK TO
SERVE. EIGHT POSITIONS FROM OUR
DEPARTMENTS IN THAT THEY CAN
RETURN TO THEIR DEPARTMENT AND
PERFORM THE WORK THAT THEY ARE
REALLY HARD TO DO AT THOSE LOW.
SELF WITH. MEDIUM REQUIRE. CAN
CONCERNS. OKAY IS THERE ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC THAT WANT
TO READ THE COMMITTEE. SAYING
NONE QUESTION FOR THE COMMITTEE.
SIMILAR TO PREVIOUS- ITEM IT
MAY BE A- POLICY ISSUE HERE
ABOUT THE DATA SHARING AND
WHAT'S VOLUNTARY. AND WHAT'S
NOT AND MAYBE WE CAN SPEAK TO
THAT A LITTLE BIT ALL THAT JOY
ARE THE STATE'S SHIFT OUT OF
OFFICER WHO JUST RECENTLY
STARTED HERE AT THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AND TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT DATA SHARE AND- AND
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN- MAY BE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE DATA HOW
THAT KIND AND PLEASE HEAR. OKAY
ON THE DATA SHARING- ADDRESSING
IT ESSENTIALLY IT
ADMINISTRATIVE STREAMLINED
STRATEGY SO RIGHT NOW- UNDER OF
AGENCIES FACE A SUITE OF
PRIVACY REGULATIONS ON WHICH
DICTATE ALLOWABLE USE INCLUDE
WHAT'S ALLOWED FOR DATA
SHARING- BUT TO THE EIGHT IS
HAVE. AND GREEN. AND IT TO BE
IN A CO. THIS IS AN
ADMINISTRATOR STREAM MOVE TO A
SINGLE FRAMEWORK TO OPERATE
UNDER THE EXISTING ROBUST SET
OF PRIVACY REGULATIONS THAT
AGENCIES WORK BUT TO STREAMLINE
THE NEGOTIATIONS IF YOU WILL
HOW TO DO THAT. FAIR TO SAY
THAT IT IT IT IT'S IT CREE TO
ONE CONTRACT FOR HOW THAT DATA
CAN BE SHARED AS OPPOSED TO
EVERYONE NEGOTIATING SOMETHING
DIFFERENT THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT
SO IT CREATES A SAME BASELINE
OF DATA PROTECTION AND
STANDARDS AND- CREATES A SINGLE
PLACE WHERE WE GET TO RECORD
AND DOCUMENT IN MONITOR THAT.
RIGHT EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT MORE.
SURE SO- TO RIGHT NOW- STATE
AGENCIES FACE A ROBUST SET OF
PRIVACY REGULATIONS SO
EVERYTHING FROM YOU KNOW THE
STATE INFORMATIONS ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN TO- A
WHOLE BUNCH OF FEDERAL
REGULATIONS WHETHER IT'S FOR BY
HIPAA WE HAVE MANY STATE
EQUIVALENTS THERE'S AT YOU I'M
SURE YOU'RE OFF YOUR WITH A
WHOLE. LIST OF THEM THOSE ARE
OF COURSE THE GOVERNOR LAW FOR
WHEN WE HAVE ALLOWABLE SHARING
ACROSS AGENCIES IN SO INCLUDING
TO IMPROVE SERVICES FOR THE
RECIPIENTS GRAHAM SO FOR
EXAMPLE MANY STATING THERE
SERVING THE SAME APPLE
RELATIONS YOU WANT TO BE ABLE
IN HOLISTIC CARE. ON AS I HAS A
CLEANING GOES THOSE OF
AGREEMENTS COSTLY AND TIME
CONSUMING THIS CREATES A SINGLE
FRAMEWORK FOR. I'M A SINGLE
COME CARP CONTRACTUAL FRAMEWORK
THAT ESSENTIALLY REQUIRES THE
ROBUST DATA PROTECTION AND
CONFORM TO ALL THE EXISTING
LAWS WHILE HAVING A SINGLE
AGREEMENT AND THEN IN EACH
INSTANCE OF DATA SHARING
THEREFORE THEY HAVE WE HAVE TO
DOCUMENT ON WHAT'S CALLED THE
BUSINESS USE CASE PROPOSAL
APPLE. THEN TRACK THOSE IN
TRACK CONTRACT COMPLIANCE WITH
DOES THAT HELP EXPLAIN. THE
PERSON WHOSE INFORMATION IS
BEING SHARED FROM AGENCY TO
AGENCY DO THEY KNOW THAT THAT'S
BEEN DONE SO HOW DO THEY KNOW
THAT SURE ALL AGENCIES FACE-
WATER CALL NOTICE REQUIREMENTS
THAT THEY HAVE TO GIVE EITHER
IN THEIR ARMS ARE ON THEIR SITE
SAYING WATER THE USES OF IT AND
COVERED BY THAT TYPE OF AND IN
THOSE ARE TYPICALLY FLOWING
ALREADY FROM THE EXISTING
PRIVACY REGULATION. I MEAN.
SEVEN GET ODOR SO THAT OR IS
THAT JUST THE AGENCY. ST THIS
IS HOW WE'RE GOING TO HANDLE
JUST AT THE PERSON ACTUALLY
KNOW THAT THEIR INFORMATION IS
BEING SHARED FROM AGENCY TO
AGENCY SO THOSE NOTICES ARE
INCLUDED WHETHER YOU SIGN A
FORM OR ON YOUR WEB SITE OR FOR
A ON AGENCY WEB. SAMPLE THESE
ARE THE ALLOW USES THAT EXTENT
IF WE- AND ON. PERMISSIBLE
THOSE LWS. THOSE RIGHT SO FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN YOU WANT TO
PROVIDE THIS TO SOMEONE. THIS
IS NECESSARY IN ORDER PROVIDE
THAT SERVICE THAT CONCEPT OF
ALLOWABLE USE. SO THIS IS
DEFINITELY IN THE IN THE LITTLE
BIT. A LITTLE BIT DEEPER BUT
YEAH I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ADD
WERE VERY CAN WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
VERY STRICT CONCERNED IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR RIGHT YEAH ABOUT
THE USES OF DATA AND GIVEN
PROPER NOTICE. TO YOU TO KNOW
REALLY UNDERSTAND YOUR
INFORMATION BEING SHARED I
WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT WE- ALSO
EXPAND FOR. WITHIN OUR OWN. NO
I WAS JUST GONNA SAY I THINK
ACTUALLY WITH THE PASSAGE OF
CCPA WERE LIFTING UP OUR
EXPECTATIONS OF PRIVATE ACTORS
TO BE COMPARABLE TO WHAT
GOVERNMENT HAVE BEEN GOVERNMENT
AGENTS BEEN OPERATING. EARLY
TECH. YEAH I THINK THIS IS A
REALLY GREAT POLICY DISCUSSION
TO HAVE IT'S A VERY INTERESTING
TOPIC AND- YOU KNOW IT'S A
LITTLE SEPARATE AND APART FROM
THE REQUEST THAT'S HERE BEFORE
YOU WHICH IS REALLY JUST SOME
WORKLOAD TRANSPARENCIES IT
SUGGESTS MANY THINGS THAT WILL
BE WORKING IN OUR AGENCY- BUT
WE'RE NOT ACCESSING FOR YOU
KNOW. RESOURCES RELATED REMAINS
JUSTIN ELLIS. AMPLE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THIS POSITION WILL
BE WORKING. ON SO. WHAT I
UNDERSTAND WE'RE SENATOR EYES
SO IT'S COMING FROM MY THAT
THAT. THE STATE DOESN'T TAKE
PERSONAL PEOPLE'S PERSONAL
INFORMATION AND SELL IT FOR ANY
PURPOSE. ASCERTAIN THAT THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR OTHER KINDS OF
SERVICES OR MEANT PARTICULAR IN
THAT SOCIAL SERVICE AREA. ALL
WITHIN THE SAME DEPARTMENT BUT
DIFFERENT- DIFFERENT PIECES OF
THE ORGANIZATION SEE THAT.
WE'RE OKAY IT'S- BEEN A MESS ON
THE TABLE MANY CASE AND WE
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION PROBABLY IT SEEMS
LIKE A VERY INTERESTED IN THIS
TOPIC AND WE COULD COME AROUND
AND I'M YOU KNOW. HOW TO MEDIAN
ON THIS TOPIC AND JACKETS JERRY
LIKE TALK MY EAR OFF ON IT I
LOVE IT. TALK YOU AT TOP ABOUT
THIS POLICY IN THAT. I THINK
THAT WOULD BE GREAT. SO THIS IS
A- HOLD OPEN ITEM. BELIEVE I'VE
ASKED IF THERE IS A PUBLIC
COMMENT AND- THERE NIELSEN YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS IN REGARDS
OKAY VERY GOOD THIS IS A HOLLOW
FOR OPEN ITEM CAPRI SHEET THE
OFFER TO COME AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION THAT NEXT ITEM IS
THE- COUNSEL. YOU WHICH IS SIX
AND DISASTER PREPAREDNESS. WHAT.
VERY VERY WE'RE DOING VERY WELL.
OTHER THAN THAT SPELLED MAYES
BUILT WATER. I WAS SITTING ON
MY HANDS WELCOME. OKAY. THANK
YOU MATT. THE USER MIKE AS WELL
AS MY TEACHER FOUR AM. I MAN
DOWN CRAWFORD THE DIRECTOR THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL. THESE
ARM BY STAFF MEMBERS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AYE ANNIKA BREWERY.
AND KRISTIN MARVELOUS ARE AT
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S DIRECTOR
OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS. OUT
FIRST THING I'D LIKE TO SAY IS
THAT I'M REALLY PROUD THAT- THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL IS A
STATE AGENCY THAT'S KNOWN FOR
THE BEST RESPECT RESPONSIVENESS
IN EQUITY THAT WE HAVE WITH ALL
OF CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY. IN
THESE ITEMS A LOT TO DO WITH
THAT. NOW BEFORE WE BEGIN
THOUGH I LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WE'RE SITTING HERE BEFORE
YOU THE MORNING AFTER THE
GOVERNOR'S ANNOUNCEMENT AM.
REGARDING THE COVE IN NINETEEN
POLICY ON MASS GATHERINGS
GREATLY IMPACTS INTO OUR WORK
AND OUR WHOLE FIELD THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY WILL. HIT
ANYBODY WHO HAS A PUBLIC
PERFORMANCE ADVANCE AT
BASICALLY THE CORE OF MANY MANY
OF THE ARTS BUSINESS GOALS THAT
OUT WE- AARON SERVICE SERVE AND
THEIR LIFELINE FOR INDIVIDUAL
ARTISTS AS WELL THE IMPACT IS
LIKELY TO BE THE GREATEST FOR
THE UNDER RESOURCE. IN THE LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WE ARE
SURVEYING THE FIELD TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE FINANCIAL
IMPLICATION OF THIS CRISIS AND
CONTINUE TO ASSESS THE IMPACT
ON OUR GRANTEES AS WELL AS ON
THE ARTS LANDSCAPE OVERALL. BUT
JUST ABOUT THE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE EFFECT OF THEIR STATE
FUNDED ADVANCE. WE'RE HERE
TODAY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL IF
TEN POINT FIVE MILLION OF ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND INTO OUR
BUDGET THESE FUNDS ARE TO BE
ALLOCATED IT THREE DIFFERENT
WAYS. AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO SAY
THERE'S THREE DIFFERENT WAYS
BUT THEY ALL CONNECT WHICH IS
THE BEAUTY OF OUR WORK IS
INCREASINGLY SO ALL OF OUR WORK
IS INTERSECTIONAL. NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IS TO EXPAND THE
CULTURAL DISTRICT PROGRAM AND
SUPPORT OUR FOURTEEN. PILOT
COHORT OF CULTURAL DISTRICTS.
FOURTEEN DISTRICTS THAT
CURRENTLY HOLD THE STATE
DESIGNATION REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA THROUGH A VARIETY OF
LENSES GEOGRAPHICALLY
CULTURALLY AND ARTISTICALLY.
THE INTENT OF CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL DISTRICTS PROGRAM IS
TO HIGHLIGHT THE CULTURAL
LEGACY FOR STATES MOST VALUABLE
RESOURCE. IT'S DIVERSITY. THE
PROGRAM INSPIRES TO ASSIST
CALIFORNIANS IN LEVERAGING THE
STATE'S CONSIDERABLE ASSETS IN
THE IT IS OF WILSHIRE.
CREATIVITY AND DIVERSITY AS A
NATIONALLY SET OUT IN THE
ENABLING JUST LATE IN EIGHT.
WHY EIGHT NINE MR DEALING WITH
FOUR DIGITS HERE. HAVE ONE
EIGHTY NINE THE INITIAL COURT
IS A ROBUST FOUNDATION FOR WHAT
OF FUNDED CULTURAL DISTRICT
PROGRAM CAN BE SO WE'RE
BUILDING ON SOMETHING THAT.
THAT WE FEEL STRONGLY ABOUT-
BEING SUCCESSFUL. IT CAN BE THE
INTERSECTION OF MUCH OF OUR
WORK INCLUDING ARTISTS KEEPING
ARTIST PLACE. THROUGH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AFFORDABLE
WORKSPACE AN ECONOMY WITH
INNOVATION AND CREATIVITY SEAT
SITTING AT ITS CENTER HEALTH
AND WELL BEING EVERYTHING THAT
CREATES OMMUNITY RESILIENCY. I
AM GOING TO EXPLAIN WHERE THE
ONE MILLION WOULD GO UP TO TEN
POINT FIVE THE ONE MILLION IS
TO DEVELOP DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT ARTS COUNCIL'S
BEEN INVOLVED IN. QUITE A LONG
TIME- AND REALLY SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN WE'VE BEEN GETTING
REGULAR UPDATES ON OUR WEBSITE
AT I'M PUTTING TOOLS AND
RESOURCES OUT THERE TO OUR
FIELD- BUT MORE SPECIFICALLY
REAP IF WE PUT TOGETHER. AND
ENGAGE NINETEEN. AND SO THE
GOAL OF THIS ONE MILLION IS TWO
X. ON THAT WORK SO IT'S TO
DEVELOP DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
GUIDELINES AND BEST PRACTICES
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TO
PROTECT AND PRESERVE RESOURCES
AND ART AND- THAT LANGUAGE YEAH
I KNOW- IT IS OUT THERE IN IN
THE BUDGET LANGUAGE BUT WE LIKE
TO ADD THE IDEA THAT ALSO.
PROTECT HAVE WORK DO YOU SPACE
DOCK. COST AND OTHER PROPERTY
INSTRUMENTS FOR TOOLS. USED BY
ARTISTS AND ARTS ORGANIZATIONS
THAT COULD BE IMPACTED BY ANY
KIND OF DESIGN. AND BECAUSE AS
WE KNOW IT IT'S NOT JUST
ARTIFACTS- SO THIS AS I SAID
WE'RE GOING TO BUILD ON THIS
WILL BUILD UP I SEE A SEIZE
WORK THAT WE- DIDN'T IN
NINETEEN WE LOCK. A SPECIAL
GIFT- AND THAT SUPPORT IN
NINETEEN. US STATE LOCAL
PARTNERS THAT I MENTIONED- AND
IT SUPPORTED THEIR COMPACT UNIT
ABILITY OF THESE ARTS AND
CULTURAL IS ATION PARTICIPATE
COMMUNITIES AT LARGE TO RESPOND
EFFECTIVELY TO DISASTERS AND
EMERGENCIES. THAT MAY AFFECT
THEIR COMMUNITIES. IT OFF
TRAINING WORKSHOP STATE WIDE
YARD A LOCAL. THERE AS A CAP.
DOES BY THE COUNTY SUPERVISOR.
IN ORDER TO BUILD LOCAL AND
CAPACITY AND ALSO TO FOSTER
DEVELOPMENT OF COUNTY WIDE
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS NETWORKS
FOR THE PRESERVATION OF
RESOURCES DURING THIS DISASTER
SO- AS I SAID THOSE WERE
NINETEEN OF THEM AND SO OF
COURSE THERE ARE MORE BECAUSE
WE KNOW HOW MANY COUNTIES THERE
ARE- AND WE ARE WE CURRENTLY
HAVE PARTNERS IN ABOUT FIFTY
THREE FIFTY FOUR OF THEM.
CURRENTLY AND SO- THE I IS THAT
THESE FUNDS WOULD BE USED TO-
SUPPLEMENTAL MATERIALS THAT WE
THE NINETEEN RECEIVED AND IN
ADDITION. REACH OUT TO THE
OTHER. STATE OF. I DID NOT
OFTEN FOR. NEW WALK TO. STILL
FOR A FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND OF
THE PROPOSED TO SUPPORT
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SERVICES.
SEATED WITH THE ABOVE
ACTIVITIES AND WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY-
AND I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT EQUITY BECAUSE THAT'S
COME IN SOME OF THE DISCUSSION
NO THAT TURNED ON THE COUNCIL
AWFUL UTILIZE OUR NEWLY
IMPLEMENTED TO TEACH IT
FRAMEWORK THAT RE OF. A ROW
STRENGTHENING FEET OF ARTS AND
CULTURE AND TO CHAMPION THE
ARTS AS ESSENTIAL NOT OPTIONAL.
IN ADDRESSING THE CHALLENGES
FACING OUR COMMUNITIES TODAY
AND IN THE FUTURE. AS PART OF
THIS HAS COME FROM OUR
PARTICIPATION GOVERNMENT
ALLIANCE AND REYES EQUITY THAT
HAS THAT HAS BEEN. GOING HAS
BEEN IMPLEMENTED FOR THE PAST
THREE YEARS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCILS PARTICIPATED IN
THE CAPITAL CALL FOR IT WITH.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT'S AROUND
ISSUES- WE'RE COMMITTED TO
DEVELOPING AN ORGANIZATIONAL
CULTURE THAT ACTIVELY ADDRESSES
BARRIERS. DISSIPATION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND CELEBRATES THE
CONNECT WITH AN INSECT. WELL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. SO THIS
FRAMEWORK THAT'S BEEN DEVELOPED
INCLUDES MANY TOOLS THAT WILL
HELP US WALK THROUGH THE
DESIGN. PROCESS HOW WE'RE GOING
TO. ALLOW THIS SIX DAY. SIXTH
GRAND. WE THAT AS A TOOL WE USE
THE DAY THAT WE LEARNED FROM
MARVIN. OF TO A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH AND ENSURE. THAT THE
BULLY ROLLED OUT OF TOTAL TO
SIX PROGRAM I'M REPRESENTS THE
STATE BOTH GRAPHICALLY AND
RACIALLY- AND THAT WE RETAIN
HOME GROWN ART AND CULTURAL
ASSETS. THOSE COMMUNITIES AND
THAT WE MEDICAID DISPLACEMENT
FOR GROUPS SUCH AS ARTISTS. LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS AND ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS. GOOD HELLO HI SO
WE KNOW THAT IN GENERAL WE
THINK THEY'RE PRICED APPEARS
REASONABLE IF IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES-
BUT WE WOULD NOTE THAT-WHEN IT
WE THINK ONE OF THE GREAT
VALUES OF POTENTIALLY EXPANDING
THIS BOTH PROGRAMS OF THE MAIN
PROGRAMS AT THE OPPOSING FINE
THEY'VE MALL SCALE THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS. TO GIVE THE A
MORE YEARS THE HOW THEY-
OPERATE AB. THE STATE MAKES A-
OF WHETHER. TO INVEST IN THESE
AS ACTIVITIES ON A LONG TERM
MAYBE ONGOING BASIS I'M
SWEEPING THAT'S A REASONABLE
APPROACH BUT WE THINK IN ORDER
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE STATE
HAS. INFORMATION AT THE END OF
THE YEAR TWO OR THREE YEARS-
PERIOD WHERE THIS THESE NEW
PILOTS ARE. ARE OCCURRING. IN
TO HAVE. GOALS FOR THEM AS WELL
AS MEASURABLE OUTCOMES. PART OF
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE TO OLD ONE
AND I'M- WE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. ESTABLISH SPECIFIC
GOALS FOR THE PROGRAM COULD
CIVIC. BUT NOT GOAL. ONE OF THE
KEY GOAL FOR THESE HAVE. AND IF
IT'S MEANT. I'M OF THE INITIAL
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
CONSULTANT OUT IS TODAY WAS
THAT THAT WAS MY BEAST IN THE
PROGRAM AND THEN TO- SECOND
PART WE THINK THAT SHOULD BE
DONE THROUGH TRIP BUDGET
TRAILER LEGISLATION AND ALSO
WITH BUDGET TRAILER LODGE
SHOULD WE THINK THAT THAT ALSO
SHOULD BE TO AND THE VALUE.
REALLY FROM THOSE. THAT WE
THINK THAT'LL JUST AND THAT THE
STATE HAS A BETTER INFORMATION.
I'M YOU KNOW IN TWO OR THREE
YEARS WHEN WE MIGHT BE SITTING
HERE AGAIN. HE ABOUT REMINDED
DO THIS ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
THERE'S CERTAINLY PROMISED TO
THESE PROGRAMS- BUT- THAT THE
CHALLENGES IS MAKING SURE THAT
WE- REALLY KNOW WHAT WHAT WE'RE
GETTING FOR THAT'S FINE. VERY
GOOD- OR ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS ITEM. HELLO CHECK A RESUME
KISS ME TO MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PETER COMISKEY AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO REPRESENT ALL FOURTEEN
OF THE PILOTS CULTURAL
DISTRICTS AND WE ARE MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
DISTRICT COALITION. WHILE THE
NUMBER OF THE CULTURE DISTRICTS
WISH THEY COULD HAVE BEEN AND
TEN THE STAMP CHOI UNDERSTAND
THAT WAS NOT POSSIBLE FIRST I
FULLY SUPPORT THE FULL TEN
MILLION- I'M JUST HERE TO SPEAK
ABOUT THE NINE- AND FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF. SUPPORT YOUR-
YOUR AGENCY- THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL IS BRICK ENGAGE
WITH COMMUNITY- AND SUPPORTIVE
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN HER
EXCELLENT. FIRST THING STOP
BEING SUCH A COMPANY REVIEW. OF
THE PILOT CULTURAL DISTRICT
PROGRAM AND YOUR MEETING
MATERIALS IT'S EXCITING THIS
NEW AND SUCCESSFUL TOOL HAS
BEEN ADDED TO THE TOKEN. IS
WITH GREATEST RISK THAT I WAS
TO PROVIDE CLARIFICATION ON
BECAUSE SOME COMMENTS THAT WERE
PROVIDED I WELCOME YOU ARE
EATING TO ENGAGE WITH ME OR ANY
OF THE PUBLIC COACHES DISTRICTS
BUT EXAMPLES EVIDENCE AN OUTLAW
POTENTIAL OF EXCEPTIONAL IMPACT
PROGRAM. WELL IT DOT CULTURAL
DISTRICTS WAS CHOSEN JUST A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO. TO PROVIDE
A RANGE OF CHARACTERISTICS FOR
THE FIRST CO QUOTE. SOME
ESTABLISHED AREAS. SOME RURAL
SOME OPEN. WITH SUCH A SHORT
TIME FRAME IN WHICH TO BRING A
PROGRAM HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED. I
CONSIDER RIGHT SUCCESS THAT
PERCENT ARE ALREADY REPORTING
ECONOMIC IN. IT IS SOMETIMES
YOU NOT GET THAT ACHIEVEMENT IN
PLACE. GENTRIFICATION WAS ALSO
RISE WHEN I COMMITTED OFTEN
CITED BASED UPON THE OLD MODEL
OF REDEVELOPMENT WHERE CITY
MIGHT TEAR DOWN I SHOULD CITY
COAL AND BUILD A MASSIVE
PERFORMING ARTS CENTER IN ITS
PLACE. WELL SUCH ASSETS IS
STILL VERY IMPORTANT AT
COMMUNITIES THIS IS NOT THE
CULTURAL DISTRICT PROGRAM WHAT
IT ADVOCATES FOR DELIVERANCE.
INDEED THE PROGRAM IN THE
FANTASTIC DESIGNED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL SERVES
TO DRIVE COLLABORATION. BY
EXISTING CULTURAL ASSETS TREATY
TO PROTECT CELEBRATE AND EXCITE.
YOU ONLY HAVE TO LOOK AT
EUREKA. TRUCKEE ALL LITTLE
TOKYO AS STELLA EXAMPLES. THESE
CULTURAL DISTRICT UP PROTECTING
THE ARTS AND CULTURE
COMMUNITIES FOSTERING THEM.
GROWING CELEBRATING THE- I ALSO
CARRIAGE IN MEASURING THE
IMPACT OF CULTURAL DISTRICT BY
THE ZIP CODE ANALYSIS THAT HAS
BEEN PROVIDED IN YOUR PACKET.
FIRST THESE CULTURAL DISTRICT
ARE IMPACTING CITIES AND
REGIONS NOT INDIVIDUALS OF
CODES. ALSO COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I BEING
IMPACTED BY INCREASING DEVELOP
RISING HOW COSTS AND ACCESS
ISSUES IN MANY OF THESE
COMMUNITIES AND I WOULD USE
COLOR QUITE TWENTY FOUR AT IN
SAN FRANCISCO BARRIO LOGAN IS
EXAMPLES. THE UP. WOULD SHOW
WAS. HOWEVER THE CULTURAL
DISTRICT IS WORKING TO PROTECT
THE EXISTING COMMUNITIES
EXISTING CULTURAL ELEMENTS
WITHIN THOSE COMMUNITIES
FINALLY I WOULD LEAVE YOU WITH
ONE THOUGHT THE CULTURAL
DISTRICTS PROGRAM IS AN
EXTREMELY VALUABLE AN
UNPARALLELED FORCE MULTIPLIER.
CULTURAL DISTRICTS OF
PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS ARTS AND
CULTURE NEIGHBORHOOD AND
BUSINESS IT IS A LEVERAGING
TOOL NOT JUST FOR THE DIRECT
PARTNERS IN THE PROGRAM. BUT
ALSO THE COMMUNITY IN GENERAL
FOR OTHER ORGANIZATIONS TO
RECEIVE FUNDING. WHAT IS
MISSING IS THE FUNDING
NECESSARY FOR THESE BUSY
INDIVIDUAL ORGANIZATIONS TO
WORK TOGETHER. TO DELIVER THEIR
PROGRAM ALONE IS SUCCESSFUL TO
LIVE IN THESE PROGRAMS TOGETHER
IS EXCEPTIONAL. THE DEVELOPMENT
OF CULTURAL AREAS WHERE THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FUNDS
INDIVIDUAL ORGANIZATIONS WILL
LEAD TO A MANY FOLD INCREASE IN
COLLABORATION EFFECTIVENESS AND
EFFICACY FOR ALL. OF YOUR
FUNDED PROGRAMS IN THE REGION.
THIS FUNDING WILL DELIVER A
RESOLVES TO FOCUS ON
COLLABORATION A RESULTS TO
FOCUS ON DELIVERING AND
PROTECTING COMMUNITIES IN A
HOLISTIC WAY. AND A FOCUS ON
LEVERING LEVERAGING FUNDING.
INCLUSION OF SIXTEEN YOU
CULTURAL DISTRICTS IN THE PILOT
PROGRAM ADDING TO THE FOURTEEN
EXISTE. WILL BROADEN THAT
SUCCESS ACROSS THE STATE. I AM
TOTALLY A CULTURAL DISTRICT
CONVERT. AND I ASK THAT FUNDING
BE APPROVED SHOULD YOU CHOOSE
TO LEAVE THE AUTUMN OPEN ALL
FOURTEEN OF THE EXISTING
CULTURAL DISTRICTS LOOK FORWARD
TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INSIGHT SHOULD THAT
FULL TO YOURSELVES WE'LL STOP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE. SEEING NO
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THE
RECOMMENDATION TODAY IS TO HOLD
IT OPEN I GUESS I AM. I HAVE A
QUESTION TO START WITH IS THAT-
THE INTENTION IS TO IDENTIFY A
SIXTEEN NEW- LOCATIONS. AND IN
TERMS OF THE LOCATIONS THAT YOU
CHOSE AND VERY INTERESTING AND
YOU KNOW I LOVE THE ART TO ME
TO START OFF BY SAYING THAT
AND- I IT'S THE REASON I
SUPPORTED THIS IN- OUT LAST
YEAR'S BUT- BUT- BUT THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS- AND MY
CONCERN IS I LOOK AT THE-
LOCATIONS THAT WERE CHOSEN.
THERE A HIGHLY CONCENTRATED IN
CERTAIN AREAS AND THERE THERE'S
THERE I MADE MY ISSUE IS ALWAYS
GOING TO BE RURAL AND IT'S
ALWAYS GOING TO BE COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AND IT'S ALWAYS GOING
TO BE LOW INCOME SO- WHEN I
LOOK AT THAT THERE'S A WHOLE
AREA OF THE STATE WHICH IS HUGE
THAT HAS. DOES IT HAVE. AB
EIGHT OF A GRANT INTO I'M
WONDERING IF YOU COULD TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. HOW HOW HOW
YOU CHOSE THESE IN TERMS OF
WHAT YOU WERE LOOKING FOR. AND
THEN HOW YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE
YOUR DECISIONS FOR OUR- FOR THE
FUTURE. AND ALSO THE ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED ON BY THE LA
OWES OFFICE IN TERMS OF.
MEASURABLE OUTCOMES SPECIFIC
GOALS AND THE- AND I'M
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN THE
ABILITY OF THE ORGANIZATIONS TO
LEVERAGE PRIVATE FUNDS AS WELL.
RIGHT OUT I KNOW THAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE. HAVE ANSWERS.
THERE IS A LOCAL INCHING TO THE
EDGE OF THEIR STATE SENATE I'D
IT JUST. BEFORE I. KIND OF. OUT
OUT RELY TOO LATE THAT WE HAVE.
I'M AND MATH WITH. THAT LINK TO
EVERY COUPLE DISTRICT. AND OUT.
A LOT OF SUPPORTING MATERIALS.
WE'RE WE'LL SEND BETTY ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS EIGHT HAVE
THEIR OWN WILLING TO SUPPLY
ANSWERS TO SAY THAT THERE'S A
THERE'S A LOT. THERE'S A LOT OF
BACKGROUND TO THIS AND BECAUSE
IT EVERYTHING THAT HAS BEEN
RAISED HERE IS A CONCERN OF OUR
COUNCIL. AND WE'VE BEEN IN
CONSTANT CONVERSATION ABOUT IT
AND I AM GOING TO DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES BECAUSE- I'M STILL
THE NEWBIE. I AM NOT QUITE A
SHINY AS I WAS LAST TIME I SAW
YOU ALL THAT AND STILL LOW
SHINY SO THIS WAS IMPLEMENTED
BEFORE I CAME. M. AND THESE
WOMEN ACTUALLY HAD BOOTS ON THE
GROUND DOING SITE VISITATIONS
AND STARTING THAT COVERED UP.
COMES CONVENTION. SO IN
REFERENCE TO WHAT- YOUR
CONCERNS WELL THE COMMENTS AND
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM LA
WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT
OPTION TO LOOK FOR OUTCOMES AND
DEFINE THOSE BEFORE WE ROLL OUT
THIS NEW COHORT OF CULTURE
DISTRICTS AND WE CAN DO THAT
NOW WE ALSO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
SOME. OKAY FUNDS ARE EIGHT FULL
EVA IN LONGITUDINAL EVALUATION
OF ALL OF OUR GRANT PROGRAMMING
SO WE WILL HAVE THOSE
RESEARCHERS ON BOARD THE R. F.
P. IS. CAN OUT TO IT IS THAT WE
ARE READY TO WORK WITH THOSE
EVALUATORS SO THERE WE HAVE
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THAT- I
ALSO WE ARE ALSO VERY CONCERNED
IN THE COUNCIL AS I SAID
EARLIER IS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT WE- ARE. WE
ARE THOSE LAWS I'M COMMUNITY
COMMUNITIES PART WITH. OUR
STRATEGIC FRAME THE COUNCIL
JUST TO PROVE IT IS A DECISION
SUPPORT TOOL THAT WILL TAKE US
TO THE QUESTIONS OF WHO ARE WE
SERVING. WHO ARE WE REACHING
WHERE ARE THE WE HAVE A STAT
AWHILE WE HAVE BEEN CALLED TO
THIS. PLEASE AWARE HAVE BEEN
HUNDRED SEAT. I MEAN. AND THEN
AND REFERENCE TO PRIVATE-
LEVERAGING FRY PRIVATE FUNDS
PART OF THE- A MODEL OF THE
COUPLE DISTRICTS IS THAT IT
WOULD BE AN ARTS ORGANIZATION
COLLABORATING WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT RATING WITH LOCAL
BUSINESSES AND SO THERE WOULD
BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE
COURT OF JUSTICE AS WE DEVELOP
THEIR CAPACITY. TO LOOK AT
OTHER FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES AND
PRIVATE THING AS WELL SO AND
GAZED WITH THAT IN THAT SPOT
FOR- DEVELOPMENT OF THE PROGRAM
BUT WE'RE NOT DONE WITH THE
BLIND SO INPUT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT OUR COUNCIL IS
LOOKING AT MAKING SURE THAT WE
DO AS MUCH AS WE CAN TO REVIVE
HIS GUIDE AND SO WE FOR. THE
COMMUNITY AND MAKES. YOUR GRAPH
THAT IS NOT WASTE THE AND
SECTION SO IT IS PART OF WHAT
WE WANT TO DO IN THE THAT TIME
TO BE OF IT AS WE DO WITH OUR
PROGRAM PROGRAM THEN IN RECENT
SET I WAS APPOINTED IS BECAUSE
I AM A RURAL ADVOCATE RIGHT I
ALWAYS HAVE DON AND- KNOW THAT-
SAY TO MUCH. AT JACK BATTERS.
AND IT MATTERS VERY TO THE
COUNTS. L. AND THAT WILL THEN
IT ITS GEOGRAPHY AND THEN ALSO-
DIFFERENT ART FORMS DIFFERENT
LIFE EXPERIENCES AND I WAS
REALLY HAPPY THAT THE-
CALIFORNIA- STATE FAIR- HAS
DESIGNED- MY DAD SHE PROGRAM
FOR YOUNG STUDENTS TO COME IN
TWO. DATE COMPETE AND THERE'S
NOTHING GREATER THAN HAVING
STUDENTS- LEARN A SKILL THAT IS
HAS BEEN IN THEIR FAMILY FOR.
YOU KNOW EVER AND TO SEE HOW
PROUD THE FAMILIES ARE ABOUT
THAT IN IT IT'S A COMMITMENT
THAT LEARNING AND EXCELLENCE
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT'S
WHY WE'RE SO EXCITED TO HAVE
THAT SEE IF FUNDED PROGRAM
BECAUSE SO MUCH OF THEIR OTHER
PARTS OF OUR WORK SO DEEP. CHEN
EXACT YOUR TIME ABOUT WE CAN. A
SEAT IS THAT. AS A REAL
INTERSECTION POINT WE CAN A LOT
OF OUR WERE. TOGETHER AND I
WANTED TO ADD THAT I DIDN'T-
SENT EMAIL TO YOUR STAFF
TALKING A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THAT FRAMEWORK AND HOW THAT
THAT BREAKS OUT- AND HOW THAT
REALLY DOES LOOK AT HOW WE OUT
REACHED UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES- IN ADDITION I
SHARED WITH THEM SOME PROGRAMS
THAT WE ARE RIGHT ALREADY DO
FUND- OUTSIDE. STICKS THAT
SPACE WE TARGET DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES THAT YOU MENTIONED
TODAY AND ALSO JUST MORE
SPECIFICALLY GETTING TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT HOW WE WILL
REACH OUT AS AN HONEST SAID
WITH CULTURE DISTRICTS WE
HAVEN'T YET DEVELOPED. AND
LINES AND SO WE WILL DEFINITELY
BE CHANGING HOW WE OUT REACH
BASED ON THE RESULTS WE HAVE
FROM EVALUATION ALL WE PLAN I'M-
TOGETHER. A GROUP OF A-
THROUGHOUT FIELD AND PERHAPS
DOING SOME KIND OF TOUR SO WITH
WE ARE ABLE TO BE SEEN. AND
HAVE INTERACTION WITH DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES- BUT I WILL SHARE
WITH YOU IN THE PAST WE HAD
FORTY THREE SEPARATE AND
DISTINCT ORIGINALLY APPLIED TO
BE CULTURAL DISTRICTS AND- ONE
THING INTERESTING ABOUT THERE
WERE SEVEN CRITERIA THAT WERE
LIKE THAT AND- I DON'T SEE HER
LIST THEM ALL FOR YOU BUT I'M
HAPPY TO PROVIDE THOSE. FOR YOU
IF YOU'D LIKE THAT BUT WHAT I
WILL SHOW. YOU IS YOU KNOW
THERE WERE- MANY AND THESE THAT
WOULD BE FOR THAT AB CULTURAL
DISTRICTS ADAM AUNT AND- THE
PROBLEM WAS THEY JUST MIGHT
WORK. THEY TELL SHIPS. HELLO
DISTRICTS RIGHT AND DEFINE
DEVELOP. REALLY FEEL THAT THOSE
NASCENT ORGANIZATIONS WILL BE
LIFTED BY THAT AND THAT WE WILL
OPEN THE DOOR IN THIS THESE
FUNDS WILL CERTAINLY OPEN THE
DOOR FOR MANY MORE
POSSIBILITIES. JUST TO CLARIFY
TO WHAT CRISTINA THANK THE
DEVELOPMENT SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
A TIERED FUNDING OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALSO DISTRICTS GOING
FORWARD THERE WILL BE A FULL ON
COACH DISTRICT THAT AS THOSE
PARTNERSHIP THIS KRISTIN.
MENTIONED TO TRY FACT THAT THE
BUSINESS THE ART ORGANIZATION
AND THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
THEY WOULD ORGAN IS THAT ARE
DEVELOPING THAT THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS AND THEY COULD-
UP. FOR NAY BUT THE MONEY THAT
GIVE THEM GAP TO APPLY THE NEXT
YEAR FOR MORE AND- SO WE WERE
TRY TO LOOK AT I THINK THAT'S A
VERY. SIMPLE WAY TO LOOK AT
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES I THINK
THE COUNSELORS. AS REALLY
WEIGHED IN ON THAT AND THEY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT MISSING. THOSE ORGAN SENSE
THAT ARE. ALSO READY AND THEY
JUST NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE
SUPPORT. AND WE'RE VERY
COMMITTED TO. THESE DISTRICTS
HAVING A BURST PIPE BUT FUNDING
PORTFOLIO BECAUSE OF THAT COOL
SUSTAINABILITY RIGHT IT TOTALLY
DOES. A REGIONALLY SUPPORTED.
AND WHERE WHERE EVER THAT IF
THEY HAVE FUN START TO. SLOW
DOWN. VACANCY BE VIABLE YEAH WE
ALSO APPRECIATE PETER KAMINSKY
COMING BECAUSE HE REPRESENTS IS
COALITION OF THEM AND SO IN
DEVELOPING THESE NEW DISTRICTS
WE DEFINITELY BELIEVE THAT
THESE FOURTEEN DISTRICTS WILL
SERVE AS ROLE MODELS OR MENTORS
FOR. AND I THINK THAT WILL
REALLY HELP THEY'RE SUCH A
CLOSE GROUP AND THEY'RE WORKING
TOGETHER TO ATTACK EACH OTHER.
OKAY THAT WILL HELP. IN ORDER
BRUCE COME TOGETHER FOR
PARTNERSHIP HAVE IDEAS HOW.
MUCH THAT WOULD BE THAT WOULD
BE REALLY HELPFUL BECAUSE OF A
LOT OF THESE DISTRICTS JUST
WHEN I LOOKED AT HIM- ALREADY
HAVE RICH TERRACE TOURISM-
BASIS AND- AND THAT GIVES THEM.
THE RESOURCES BECAUSE YOU HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING INTO THE
AREA ALREADY- BUT IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE OFF THE BEATEN TRACK CAN
YOU YOU DON'T HAVE A BIG
TOURISM POPULATION. YOU THINK
IT'S BEAUTIFUL AND YOU LOVE THE
AREA ANYWAY YOU DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE ME IT'S MORE DIFFICULT
TO START UP BUT A DISTRICT I
THINK THIS IS MY RIGHT WHICH IS
WHY THE DEPARTMENT TO ADAM.
PHASE AND- GRAHAM OPPORTUNITY
IS REALLY IMPORTANT. RIGHT IT
ISN'T AND WE DID SHARE WITH- A
LIST OF. THREE THAT UP AND
WE'LL SEE ON THAT LIST. BECAUSE
IT IS. OFF THE PATH AND SO HOW
DO WE FIND A WAY TO MAKE SURE
THE THEY ARE INCLUDED IN THIS
THIS MY INTEREST I HAVE OTHER
FROM COMMITTEE YES. THANK YOU
FOR ALL. I REALLY. LOOK AT
CULTURE ON THE ARTS IN A WAY
THAT HELP TO MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES HEALTHIER- AND
SPECIALLY THAT KIDS GROWING UP
BUT AT AGES IN ALL GENERATIONS
SO I GUESS I'M GLAD THIS IS.
HOLDEN HOLD THIS OPEN. A LOT OF
ISSUES ABOUT THE- FOR ME TO AND
THE DISTRICTS EVEN THOUGH I WAS
HERE LAST YEAR- THE FUNDING
WENT TO DIFFERENT. OF THE
MUSEUM I WANT TO- DIFFERENT
SOURCES BUT- THIS. YOU KNOW
JUST ECONOMICALLY- YOU KNOW
MOST OF THESE NEW DISTRICTS ARE
OUR MOST OF THESE FOURTEEN
DISTRICTS ARE IN. ABOVE THE
POVERTY LEVEL YOU KNOW IN THE
STATE- AND THERE'S OTHER ISSUES
I'M NOT QUITE SURE EXACTLY HOW
THE GRANT. WORK WITH THE
DISTRICT- AND WHERE THAT
LEVERAGING REALLY HAPPEN. HAPPY
TO HEAR THAT- THIS IS. THIS IS
A- LEVERAGE YOU KNOW OTHER
FUNDING I DON'T SEE HOW AND
WHERE THAT HAPPENS. AND TO HARD
CHAIRS HERE EVEN A PLACE LIKE
LOS ANGELES THAT HAS A LOT OF
TOURISM THOSE TOURIST DOLLARS
DONGLE INTO COMMUNITY NO WE CAN
MEANING THEY DON'T GO INTO
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. ARE
ALWAYS TREATED SEPARATELY FROM
YOU KNOW THE BEACHES. GETTY
MUSEUM RIGHT YEAH SO
UNDERSTAND- EVEN IN IN AREAS
WHERE THERE'S LOTS OF. TOURISM
IT DOES I GET INTO THE-
ENTITIES TO BE ABLE FOSTER
THEY'RE ALWAYS AT THE EDGE YOU
KNOW- NO LEAKS IN THE ROOF OF
THIS LET ME KNOW THEATER AS IT
JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE WHEN
YOU HAVE ALL THESE DOLLARS SO I
REALLY WANT IT YOU KNOW DEEPER
INTO HOW THIS ALL FITS
TOGETHER- ALL. AND ALSO YOU
KNOW TO KNOW THE OTHER
DISTRICTS ARE HOW THEY HAVE
FUNCTIONS WHAT'S BEEN THEIR
SUCCESS HOW DO YOU MEASURE THE
SUCCESS- AND HOW. ARTS COUNCIL
IS HELPING TO GET DOLLARS I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING A
BETTER IDEA OF WHAT THIS ALL IS
SO WE CAN USE THIS NO WAY HELP.
ME IS A DON'T GET DOLLARS RIGHT
AND NOT JUST FEEL THE REAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. I THANK YOU.
THIRTY MY COLLEAGUES A LITTLE
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE. THIS
COUNCIL HAS COME A LONG WAY STE.
MY WIFE SERVE THERE FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. AND REMEMBER
YEARS THEIR WHOLE BUDGET WITH
ONE MILLION DOLLARS REMEMBER
AND THEY HAD TO GO GET MONEY
WHATEVER THEY COULD FROM
WHEREVER THEY COULD SO THE
COUNCIL IS BECOME VERY ADEPT AT
THAT. AND HERE WE'RE TRYING TO
HAVE A NOT A LUXURY OF SOME
OPPORTUNITIES TO GREATLY EXPAND.
A COUPLE YEARS AGO WE WERE
EXPANDING AND I GUESS YOU'RE
STILL DOING SOME MARGIN
CORRECTIONS. WORK AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT THAT WE HAD AN
INSTITUTION FOR MANY YEARS AND
THAT. THERE WAS NOTHING FOR AND
THAT WAS ABLE TO BE REVITALIZED
IF YOU WILL. SO I'M GLAD THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THE COUNCIL NOW AND THAT
THEY HAVE SOME MORE RESOURCES.
AND THE FUTURE. IT WAS A VERY
VERY BLEAK TIME FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS. AND I HAVE TO MAKE AN
OBSERVATION TO YOU FOLKS- YOU
IT TO COUNSEL LOW MARYLAND MY
AFFINITY FOR ART. FOR CHRISTMAS
THIS YEAR MY STAFF COMMISSION
THE PERSON WHO DOES THESE. WHAT
CAR BEARS THE BLACK BEAR DINERS
YEAH HE LIVES UP IN PARADISE.
HE TOOK ONE OF THE TREES. THE
CARD A BEAR FOR OUR HOME- AND
DURING THE HOLIDAYS I'M LOOKING
AT THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO WHAT
I'M GOING TO CALL IT. HIS NAME
IS- DICE. BUT HOW VERY
APPROPRIATE FOR THE BATTLES
THAT WE HAD WITH THE FIRE.
STATION THIS IS A SMALL THING
BUT TO SEE. PRODUCT OF THAT
GREAT DISASTER. TRANSLATED INTO
A BEAUTIFUL WORK OF ART. THAT
WILL BE IN DURING AND UNDER A
CONSTANT REMEMBRANCE OF THAT
TRAGEDY AND HOW THAT COMMUNITY
HAS COME BACK. FROM THE TRASH
IT IT IT'S AN EXPANSION OF THE
MISSION OF ART AND WHAT WE CAN
DO WITH ART IN CALIFORNIA SO
WHAT WILL THE FORTY WORKING
WITH YOUNG. THAT'S A THAT'S A
BEAUTIFUL STORY- THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THAT WITH THIS BECAUSE
THAT IS A BEAUTIFUL STORY- WELL
THIS IS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING. THERE THIS IS A HOLDOVER
OPEN ITEM SO WE WILL HOLD IT
OPEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH PERFECT THANK.
YOU HAVE SUPPORT HERE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE GET IT RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. YEAH THAT
LOOK LIKE LOOKS LIKE IT
CONCLUDES OUR- OUR WORK TODAY
SO THIS COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.